Hello Dorks.
Hello Fellow dorks.
How about that?
That's better because that means I'm a Dork to this episode of the podcast is
brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is the all in one platform for you to create your own website,
a very easy way to do it in a,
in a very beautiful professional way.
Squarespace has incredible designs and it is a simple drag and drop interface.
They offer 24 seven support.
It's a website where you can create your own website and you could do it very
swiftly and easily and it would work on everything.
It'll work on an iPhone or to work on an android phone and to work on windows.
It'll work on Unix,
it'll work on anything you want and that was always a big problem.
Before Squarespace was around,
before it used to be like even if you've got a good designer would made a
website for you.
It was always like when you would go to different platforms,
he would try it on.
The Safari Browser would look all fucking wacky and shit,
but now they've got it nailed.
You can also start an online store like within minutes.
It's one of the easiest things you'll ever do.
That looks awesome.
You won't be able to believe how cool the websites you can create on
Squarespace.
We had a contest last year and uh,
it wasn't a matter of trying to find good ones.
It was a matter of there was too many good ones.
It's too easy to do.
A plan started eight bucks a month and that includes a free domain name.
If you sign up for a year free domain name,
I think I slept through that domain name,
responsive design,
your site will look awesome.
E commerce,
you could sell digital audio if you're like a musician or something like that.
Do you want to have online downloads?
If you're a comedian,
you want to sell online downloads,
you can do that shit and for a free trial and 10% off of your first purchase,
go to squarespace.com and enter the code word Joe.
They also have a logo creator.
Say,
if you one of those dudes,
you need like a fucking,
like a logo,
like a tiger woods,
a tw tiger has his own logo,
whereas on his own shit,
he want a logo.
Squarespace has a logo creator.
We can create a clean,
simple logo design for yourself in meds.
Go to squarespace.com and during the code word Joe and save yourself 10% off and
a free trial,
10% it's good.
squarespace.com go there and joy were also brought to you by stamps.com
stamps.com is another way that the Internet has made things more simple.
It's a beautiful,
beautiful invention.
stamps.com allows you to,
within the confines of your own home,
your own office without going to the actual post office using just a regular
computer and irregular printer,
you can buy a Fishel us postage for any letter or any package.
You could print it up on your printer.
I mean it's,
it's hard to believe how easy it is.
stamps.com allows you,
especially with this offer.
If you go to stamps.com and click on the microphone in the upper right hand
corner and entering the code word j r e you get $110 bonus offer,
which includes a free digital scale and up to 55 bucks and free postage.
You slap your packages on that scale.
Um,
you print up whatever the,
the postage is on your regular computer,
put it on the box and then hand it to the post man and your day.
Any dignity done no due she fucking lines at the post office.
No nonsense.
Don't talking to some lady or man at the counter who does not want to way your
bullshit.
And if you're like thinking about starting your own business,
this is the method.
This is the way,
this is the path.
If you're thinking about like,
oh,
I need to get the fuck out of this,
nine to five bullshit grind working for somebody else's,
this is,
this is for the birds,
man.
This is what you do.
Start a business,
figure it out,
sell something,
do whatever you gotta do.
And view something like stamps.com and you can do it all yourself.
Uh,
Brian sends out all of those desk,
squad.tv,
kitty cat shirts.
He does all that,
the hats and shit.
He sells a bunch of things.
Now he does that all himself does it all in his house.
He goes house,
it looks like a goddamn shipping containment facility.
Um,
and he does it all to stamps.com.
It's super easy to do.
Uh,
anyone that sends things through the post office,
you will save a massive amount of time.
And on top of that you will save money.
And that's the beautiful thing about stamps.com technology is making your life
easier.
You freaks right now,
use the code word j r e for this special offer,
which again includes no risk trial,
$110 bonus.
Offer a digital scale and up to 55 bucks worth of free postage.
So go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click@themicrophoneatthetopofthehomepageandtypeinjrethatstamps.com and j r e.
And last but not least,
we are brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that is o n n I t on it is a human
optimization website.
And what that means is we sell you all the most groovy shit that we find.
And if we don't find it,
we want,
we get it made.
What we,
what we sell is all things that help human performance,
whether it's your,
the way your brain works,
your mood itself.
We literally sell mood supplements.
It's been known for a long time that a supplement called five HTP.
It enhances your body's ability to produce serotonin.
It's the raw building blocks of Serotonin l trip to fan and five HTP.
And what it is is El Tryptofan converts to five HTP,
five HTP converts to Serotonin.
And we have both of those along with vitamins like vitamin B six,
which is a converting catalyst.
Um,
what it,
what it is essentially is your food that you eat.
It's very difficult to get a diet that's like as rich in nutrients as your body
requires to function optimally.
And everybody's concerned with,
uh,
you'll,
you,
you read all these,
um,
articles,
especially by,
uh,
the,
the no nonsense type folks.
The ne'er do you know,
like these,
there's a bunch of people that believe that Paul,
your needs is a good diet.
Yeah.
Don't need all the vitamins.
Vitamins are bad for you might have a wall tell you what vitamins,
you know,
she don't need them.
It's a waste of money.
Your peanut all out.
It's not a waste of money.
If you want to function at your very best,
you really need to optimize your nutrients.
The best way to do that is to get your blood work done,
find out what you're low in and then,
uh,
and then supplement those things.
Talk to someone who's an actual expert,
but I guarantee you five HTP and l trip to fan those two things,
especially with the,
the mix that's provided with,
uh,
with um,
um,
uh,
new mood,
which provides a magnesium,
vitamin D three.
It's all the idea is to give you this synergistic effect where your body is able
to produce more serotonin and it literally will make you a happier person.
It sounds ridiculous,
right?
Like a vitamin supplement that makes you a happier person.
Give it a shot,
bitches.
It's so po.
It's so potent that people that are on antidepressants,
they actually tell them to not take five HTP.
They'd tell him to not take things like new mood because you,
you can get what's called Serotonin Syndrome where you have too much serotonin
kind of Freaky,
Huh?
Don't do that.
Um,
anyway.
Uh,
all the other things that we carry are,
you know,
we,
we carry the best strength and conditioning equipment,
kettlebells,
battle ropes,
steel maces steel clubs,
things along those lines.
If you are a person who's into improving your body and improving the way your
body functions while your brain functions go to on a.com and a guarantee,
you will find something for you.
O,
n n,
I.
T.
A.
All of our supplements have a 100% money back guarantee.
The first 30 pills,
you have 90 days to send that shit back or to not even send that shit back.
Rather I should,
you don't even have to send it back.
All you have to do is say,
this doesn't do anything for me and you get all your money back.
No one's trying to rip you off.
We're just trying to sell you the best shit that you could possibly buy on it.
Dot Com use the code word Rogan and save 10% off any end.
All supplements.
All right,
that's it.
Crystally is here.
Well,
fuck around.
Play the music and let's get started.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Young Chris Dalea out there in the wild.
The wild of Hollywood on a billboard.
I'm driving up La Cienega.
I see your face with some other people.
I don't know.
Looking sexy.
I like young.
I like to use young.
Yeah,
you're still young,
but I don't know.
No,
I,
I still kind of feel young.
I was 34 yeah,
I'm 47 today.
And do you feel 47 no,
but I take all kinds
of shit right?
Me Film fucking fresh.
Yeah.
Hormones and fucking athletic supplements and Shit.
You know,
guys like guys like you just made me feel like I'm going to die soon because
you,
you seem like a buddy.
I would hang with like that and you know you are,
but like you seem like somebody that's my age and then when I realize,
oh yeah,
you're not,
I'm like,
how the fuck am I going to feel?
Because I definitely feel less energetic than I was when I was 25.
Yeah.
But do you,
what do you do about it?
It's all about what do you do about your hand?
Exercise.
How often do you exercise?
I used to exercise so sides humping.
Yeah.
No,
that's,
that's my cardio
cardio.
I used to exercise so much and I just don't,
man.
Yeah,
you got to,
and especially when you hit your thirties.
Is it hot in here,
Jamie?
Or is it me?
Yeah.
Turn the AC on,
man.
I'm fucking sweating.
I think he'll be two screws to Leah.
Been in the room,
young Kristalina um,
you gotta take care of it,
otherwise it starts to atrophy.
There's no other way around it.
I know.
If you don't,
your body's gonna slowly atrophy.
I gotta I gotta and I just keep saying I got it.
But then it's like I do the roads,
so you know,
I do the road and it's like,
so it's like,
when are you going to fucking start?
And then it's like,
you know,
that's the hardest part.
I know what you know,
you're like,
yeah,
you just fucking do it.
But it's like you just got to write it down.
That's the number one thing.
What do you mean?
Write it down?
Write down what you have to do in a day and then do that.
Like
the writing and the down thing.
It's fucking hard putting the pen
and you know,
I'm not,
I'm really not lazy.
I'm really not.
Like,
I know you're not constantly doing sets.
You're always working on your act.
I see you at the Improv.
You were there almost every night.
You're there constantly.
Yeah.
You're not lazy when it comes to stand up.
No,
not at all.
But that's also because stand up is like just such a rewarding thing now.
You know?
Right.
Immediately.
People are like,
yeah,
you know,
but if you work out,
there's nobody there that's like,
yeah,
but if you don't see,
like if you had an amazing body and he took your shirt off and people went,
Oh shit,
Chris,
you're right.
And then became what you have now.
He'd be like,
what the fuck happened to my body?
My amazing body.
But now you just used to having a normal body,
right?
And so it's become the,
yeah.
The other thing is too,
like I'm pretty lucky with jeans,
my jeans.
So I'm like,
you know,
I'm like,
Hey,
I,
I don't know if I can get to do shit,
you know?
Yeah.
You're not going to get fat really easy.
And I eat,
I eat pretty well.
I don't eat like Shit,
you know?
So that's more for people that don't like,
they have no slow genes and the mental,
what happens?
They just start getting fat really quickly.
That's it.
Dot.
It is a drag that is really,
you're just,
those are the cards do ectomorph it's what it's called,
right?
Our endomorph endomorph and morph is the fat one.
Ectomorph is the people that can't put on weight no matter what they do,
I will start to,
well,
someday don't want to start by when it's already fading though.
Yeah.
You know,
like right now you're still look good.
Yeah.
You look athletic and a tram.
Good,
good,
good.
Everything's good.
Yeah,
it'll go though no matter what.
But then there's like,
I have this guy who does my podcast,
sometimes it trainer's name is Steve Maxwell,
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt 60.
What is he?
63,
64 64 fucking guy.
Looks Great.
He's ripped,
shredded six pack,
works out all the time.
Just constantly add it never gives his body a chance to get old.
So flipping awesome dude.
Yeah,
I just,
you know,
my,
my thing is also like for me,
like I'll focus on one thing and I'll just obsess about it.
And what that is,
is comedy to me like that stand up to me.
I mean,
I told you I trained like Jujitsu,
right?
Five.
Yeah.
For five years.
And where did you train it again?
Uh,
with John Machado.
Ah,
right.
Um,
and,
uh,
I did it like every day and I worked out and I lifted away,
stood and it was just what I did,
right.
And then I did stand up and I was like,
ah,
what the fuck am I doing rolling around because it wasn't,
you know,
I found out that that wasn't me.
You know?
Like I got to a point where I was like,
good for me,
but it was like other guys were,
this was their life,
you know?
And then once I did stand up,
it was just so obvious that that was who I was and that was my life,
that I was like,
I'm just going to excel at this.
I feel like if I work really hard and I did well,
stand up as a strange thing.
You definitely do work really hard.
I,
like I said,
I see you there all the time,
but standup is a strange thing in that like its potential is entirely based on
like the contents of your mind and putting it all together.
And it's all the whole thing is you,
it's not like,
you know,
like Jujitsu,
there's moves,
there's armbars right triangles and you can be very creative and you could even
come up with your own moves.
But with standup,
like literally everything,
everything that you can think of could possibly drink.
Yeah.
And you can,
you can,
you know,
I remember like,
especially when I first started out not being able to figure out,
like I had Pat Pat after pad filled with these ideas that were just ridiculously
stupid idea.
They could never be comedy.
But I was trying to figure out what are the ideas that I could come up with.
It could be comedy,
you know,
cause some of them I would like still to this day,
I'll go back and find some of my old notebook and I was like,
how did you ever make it?
You fucking idiot.
How did embarrass when you read the Shit?
Yeah.
That's like when now I watch old tapes of me,
like when I watch,
it's hard.
It's hard to watch tapes from a couple of years ago.
I know.
Yeah.
It's hard to fucking look at a picture and see how you used to dress a couple of
years,
but there are some are the photos,
photos of me from Newsradio when I had earrings too.
Oh Wow.
I had earrings though.
I mean,
you know,
it's like he kicked you fucking imagine me with earrings.
No,
I can't now.
Yeah.
It's just so not me,
but I was it.
I was at the fucking mall and I was like,
I'm getting a fucking hearing.
They punch it through.
It's a fake diamond.
Absolutely.
Then I got one of those.
Yeah,
me and my roommates,
we all went at the same time.
Got Her ears pierced.
Wow.
My one roommate was crazy.
You went both ears.
Pirate style.
My brother had to hear both years.
Yeah.
That's a gangster move.
Especially in the nineties you look at and you look at those.
Yeah.
And you look at those pictures and like you think,
Oh man,
like you're like I,
how did I get any pussy?
Like for real?
Not even like I'm,
I know it's funny,
but like not even to be funny.
Like how did somebody be like,
yeah,
that guy.
Yeah.
Well girls settled just like guys side.
No,
I don't want to think of girl is settling with me though.
That doesn't mean that doesn't go well with me.
I actually stopped wearing an earring because of Jujitsu.
Oh yeah.
Cause I used to have to take it out every time I rolled.
No tape it who fucking off?
I start guys tape it.
Really?
Yeah,
just tape it.
Wow.
That's crazy.
So I don't know why they wouldn't just fucking take it out.
I know dudes who taped her ears because they have those stretchy things,
you know,
they have those giant holes in their ears and so they pull the end together.
Oh,
this is the guy who fights in the UFC?
Yeah,
they put those,
what are those things called?
Those,
I don't know,
endings things wrong.
They're called,
they're called,
what do they call it?
Plugs,
plugs.
Those things are ridiculous.
I was arc.
Yeah.
That's a whole culture is there was girls like that that'll be like,
Yo fuck that guy.
Yeah.
Cause he's got the biggest holes right here.
Right.
Well it's like,
um,
the,
uh,
those African women that have those plates,
Surrey,
Surrey women,
they have those plates in their lips and the larger the plate,
the more cattle they're worth when they get married.
Yeah.
That's what I don't know about that at all.
I mean,
I know about that.
I've seen it,
but yeah,
that's a strange choice.
It is weird when you think about,
well also,
so that's attractive to that.
Right?
I didn't want any more,
apparently the word is that,
uh,
obviously I'm not hanging around with a lot of African broads,
but the word is that it was a,
it was like much more common,
but now women are rebelling against it.
A lot of young women don't do it because they have to bang their teeth out,
their lower teeth.
Like,
like what?
As the plate gets larger,
like as you start doing that,
it starts like going into your mouth and you drool constantly.
Yeah.
And none of that man.
Like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Like just less pain always.
No,
no bang and teeth out.
Well,
it doesn't make any sense.
I just does.
It doesn't,
I mean that's a weird thing.
Like what culture like decides is beautiful.
Well yeah,
it's also like different in the world currently.
Like you go fucking thousands of miles across the world and completely different
and it's still now,
which is crazy to me.
Yeah.
Now 2014 there's a chicken Africa walking around with a giant plate on their lip
and some dude's like,
oh man,
I want to fuck that girl.
Get that plate.
I could put my food on her plate and fuck her at the same time.
But if it were us here,
we would be like,
oh yeah,
it should be too hard to focus.
She's got to play with her.
But imagine if that became hot.
Imagine if that mean if it became hot anywhere.
If you came like a style anywhere,
it could be a style anywhere else.
It just needs to catch,
right.
Yeah.
It's all what we fucking made up.
I mean like yeah,
it used to be where girls who were very fair skin were hot because that meant
they were rich and they were indoors and fucking that was awesome.
Yeah.
And then it was and the,
and the workers got all tank cause they were outside.
But then it was like,
oh fucking 10 chicks are hot because they have a lot of money because they go
vacation.
Yeah.
And then the fair girls were not hot.
Right.
And then it turned around again where was like,
well that girl doesn't want cancer.
So she's,
she's got the money to know and have the skincare,
but it's like we're just making that shit up in our minds.
Yeah.
I decided like I used to date a girl,
he's to Tan a lot in the,
I had to talk to her.
I go,
you know,
you're not,
you don't look better when you're Tan.
Right.
You look great when you pay it.
It's just you look different.
Solid.
It is.
It's not bad.
Yeah.
Like it's all in your head.
Like some girls would be like,
I can't call it,
so I'm not,
I know.
Yeah,
I don't.
And how about like girls that are tan,
like Filipino girls would be like,
I can't,
I need,
I need to get Tan.
You're like,
you are,
you got that.
You're brown.
You're lucky you don't have to do that shit and get cancer.
Well,
even weirder.
There's a lot of Filipinos that take a,
this stuff called glutathione.
It's um,
it's an amino acid,
but they haven't injected in their skin somehow to light,
to lighten their skin tone.
Like permanently lighten their skin tone.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
It was like a whole procedure involving this glutathione stuff where they,
uh,
it's very common with Filipinos.
Apparently chicks will,
yeah.
It's just kind of,
they'll just do whatever to make themselves look,
whatever.
But then there's dudes that do that too.
And that's just absolutely not.
Yeah.
There's certain things that dude's do that like immediately I can't talk to
them.
Like if you're waxing your eyebrows,
we were working out.
We have nothing to say to each other.
Yeah.
Well if you have two earrings really,
cause you have a unit brow and you want to like get that human brow trimmed.
I get that.
I get,
that's fine.
But if you have like sculpted eyebrows,
you can go fuck yourself.
Right.
Then I talk to you do.
Absolutely.
You're trying too hard,
man.
Yeah,
there is.
Yeah.
I don't even like like any,
any type of like shave some part of your beard.
Right,
right,
right.
Just let it go or have it not,
not at all.
Yeah.
Like especially if you have like stripes,
well shaved it.
I mean honestly if you're a fucking like,
you know,
fighter or some shit and you're just going to put lines in my beard because I'm
crazy to psych to be fucking,
then fine.
But if you're just like a guy and you work at crate and barrel,
right,
and you're just like,
dude,
it's fucking on with my,
with my sideburns.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
This is a lot of work involved in that.
It's just you peacock.
And Alan was talking about this once in a book he read about,
um,
the reason why men disdain men who wear a lot of jewelry.
And then it,
it goes back to,
um,
the hunting days that men who would wear like shiny,
flashy things,
they would distract animals like they'd be,
they'd be a problem.
Oh,
on hunting journeys.
And the same thing with men who talk too much.
Like men were like,
if you look at like movies where there's a,
there's a hero and the hero is like someone to be looked up to.
They were always very stoic,
very quiet elected,
and they know how to stay calm.
They keep their shit together because those are qualities valued in hunting
parties.
That's crazy.
Isn't it weird?
But it makes sense.
Yeah.
Which is like with women,
right?
Um,
the difference in the way women communicate with each other and the w difference
between the way men communicate with each other.
Like men value stoicism.
Men value a guy who can keep his shit together when,
when the chips are down.
But when women would be gathering and making,
you know,
food and Shit,
what men were off being quiet and sneaking up on animals,
the woman would be talking all kinds of shit about the men.
This motherfucker I've seen is going to remember he's running around out there
hunting.
What is beads on?
Shit.
Scary.
You know,
like that's,
that's the reason why the culture of females,
the culture of men,
it has to do with hunting and gathering.
Yeah.
That's fucking crazy and deep.
But what about then you get the movies with the female characters that are calm
and collected and cool.
Yeah.
Those are fiction.
I mean,
yeah.
Okay.
But I mean,
it's all fiction,
but then that,
yeah.
And then I'll watch that and be like,
come on.
Well,
this,
um,
this movie's going feel like I'm sexist and you are,
but not because of that.
I am too.
Um,
but not really.
I mean,
look,
just,
it's more realistic than sexist.
It's not saying that those,
those possibilities don't exist.
They can absolutely exist,
but the reality is most of the time they don't.
You know,
I think there's,
you know what anthropomorphism is?
It's like we put a human characteristics to animals,
you know,
like Yogi bear and shit.
You know,
we,
we give them a human.
We,
I think we also do that with gender and sometimes we'll give women like these
male qualities in like especially superhero women like Brian Holtzman,
you know Brian Holtzman.
Yeah.
Brian Altima had this fucking,
this bit that he was doing about Charlie's angels.
When Charlie's angels came out and Drew Barrymore was kicking people,
knocking them out,
and he goes,
he goes,
you're too fucking woman.
She's not beating up nobody.
Come here,
come here.
And he goes,
he goes,
that was my woman.
And she thought she was going to go out there,
fight crime.
I beat her fucking ass.
I beat her fucking ass right in the house.
You're a woman that guys truly funny.
He's hilarious.
He's one of the most hilarious guys that for whatever reason,
never made it.
And,
you know,
I don't,
I mean,
I got to get him on the podcast if actually definitely should.
He'd just like you,
but he'll also go,
he would go up at like 1:00 AM and walk the room.
Oh yeah.
But,
but the 17 people that stayed would be crying,
crying.
He,
uh,
I,
I'll never forget it,
sorry.
He had this bit,
the Brian Holtzman bid that I always quote about Susan Smith.
That's as she drowned her kids.
You know.
Remember that woman [inaudible] the woman who was she?
She pretended somebody else did it.
He went on stage like a week after this happened,
he goes up,
he goes,
ladies and gentlemen,
uh,
I heard there were bad kids.
They sat that close to the TV.
They didn't put away their blocks so well,
they were always spilling the milk.
Those kids will not be missed.
Oh my God.
But it's funny the way he does it.
It's weird.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's,
it's awful.
It goes awful.
It's awful.
But it's hilarious.
Yeah.
Do you remember when,
um,
there was that a Florida didn't?
It's just,
it was a really cheap airline that,
uh,
I forget what it express air or something like that.
Some Airbus,
it was like a really cheap airline and they went down the everglades and he had
this hilarious bit about,
uh,
trying to walk his dog and there's fucking body parts washing up on the shore
and these people with their fucking cheap airline tickets,
his anger and the,
that these fucking people to stupid by irregular airplane ticket and now he had
to deal with it.
Well,
I'm trying to walk my dog,
I'm trying to walk my dog and I got to pick it up feet and shit.
He had to see it.
I'm not doing the guys material any justice,
but yeah,
he's one of those guys.
Yeah.
I don't know where the fuck he is.
I don't know.
He was a meter maid.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
He actually looks like he would be a meter maid.
We'd be like this fucking guy.
And you'd be like,
what does this guy do?
What does this guy do besides this?
And the answer is he fucking goes on stage.
That's crazy.
Well,
it didn't make any sense because he was so good.
He,
he was so good.
Yeah.
Like I'm like,
how are you not like,
but what at what Ma let him to be so good was like he had this stage stage was a
store he very rarely did anywhere,
but the guy,
he would do the laugh factory sometimes.
Yeah.
And it didn't feel right.
No,
no,
no.
He would be up there with Jo Koy and shit and I know.
Right.
And then fucking Travis Bickle would come up though real life Travis pickle and
just people would be like,
oh no,
this is not for me.
Yeah.
Those guys
that everybody knows and everybody remembers that.
Um,
you know,
or like,
you know what,
when you would call comic's comic comics,
those are the guy.
Like if you,
if you ask like a lot of comments to go to the store,
who is like your 10 favorite comics ever?
A lot of them were going to say Holtzman.
Oh yeah.
Well Brody's like that,
you know?
Yes.
But Brody's catching on at least comedy central show,
Hbo,
what does it,
HBO,
Comedy Central,
but central industry.
But the Internet can help you do that.
When Holtzman was,
you know,
young,
there was no internet.
Yeah.
So it's like now people can find what they want.
Yeah,
it's true.
Well it's also true that like you used to need a network,
like we were talking about this before the podcast started,
you used to need a network and you used to need someone to come along and say,
hey,
you know you are the guy,
we're going to put you as the star of our show.
You're going to be this guy.
But now all you have to do is have like a funny video on Youtube.
And then everybody goes,
who was that guy?
And then they send it to their friends at work and next thing you know it's
passed around to [inaudible] office.
And the next thing you know like look,
a Russell Peters,
Russell Peters became gigantic,
not because of television,
because of fucking youtube.
So Russell Peters sells out the o two arena in London,
two shows in a row.
That's like 18,000 fucking seats or something like that.
I mean,
he's gigantic and that's all because just because he was funny,
nobody picked him.
Nobody.
Right.
You know,
and that can happen now,
but when Holtzman was around,
especially when Holtzman started,
it just did.
Didn't exist.
Yeah.
No network.
I would be like,
hey,
you'll be on my sitcom.
You'd be the lead.
You would never take the chance.
No Way.
He took the chance with that guy.
Who knows what the fuck he would do.
You know,
like we were talking about like guys getting in trouble for saying things off
off the author show off their show on stage as a comedian.
Yeah.
I remember,
um,
the rumor was,
I dunno if it was substantiated or not,
but that ABC had told Tim Allen to stop doing stand up while he was doing home.
Really?
Yeah.
Because,
well,
it was,
he was on this huge Sitcom and it's his stand up,
even though it wasn't even well back then.
Maybe then.
Yeah.
See,
what are you talking about?
He would talk about being a man.
Yeah.
But apparently like people could think that it was sexist or wow,
you know,
it could be too harsh for a family show.
Cause like that was the other thing with Bob Saget,
Bob Saget,
that's super family show and he's real dirty.
Right?
Like he didn't do standup at all while he was on that show at all.
I guess he didn't know.
They must've,
well I'm also,
he was getting so much money.
Maybe he just didn't feel the need to do it,
but probably it probably had something to do with his,
his willingness to say yes.
Right.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I mean I,
I,
but that to me it's like I've gotten everything from standup,
so to not do that is just weird to me.
Like I can't wait to get off set and go on stage when I was on news radio.
But did you,
you did it,
you did stand up.
Oh yeah.
Always
right.
Always.
Never stopped.
I did get lazy though.
There was a time,
uh,
in the early nineties when I first got on television,
like 94 95 I did fuck all with my act.
Oh really?
You're just doing what?
I just did what you do.
Did the jokes that I had been doing for years and I didn't write at all for how
long?
Um,
at least a year,
maybe more,
maybe more.
And then one day some of the writers from news radio came to see me at the store
and I had a late night spot and I ate
ugly.
Oh really?
I'd love to see you eat tick.
That's crazy.
I went down to,
and it was a in front of somebody.
I respected a couple of people that I respected and it just wasn't good.
And I realized that I had been coasting and I was like,
God,
I just is not good.
I the few moments in my career,
uh,
the,
the real standout eat dick moments,
like there'd been some bad.
So that's along the way,
but there's a few standout really eat plates of Shit.
You know what,
those moments made me way better.
And that,
that happened to me,
that moment of eating tic in front of those writers at the,
uh,
at the comedy store in the main room late night.
The crowd was dead.
There was no ready fad.
It was not,
there was no one there.
I mean it might've been plus the writers,
there might've been 30 other people,
uh,
when they were scattered throughout the room,
maybe 50 maximum,
I don't even think 50 but it started out a full house,
you know,
and then as the show goes on,
I got on it like probably one o'clock in the morning or something like that.
It was just,
you were on this show already,
right?
Yeah.
So how did you have such a late spot?
I always had lakes ponds and they always gave me light spots.
Yeah.
Well when I first got on news radio,
I was a non paid regular.
Mitzi used to put me on [inaudible] after the show was over.
So it would go on like afternoon Sia.
It's like when nobody knew him and see what it was.
But actually I think of me,
he might have already gotten an HBO special by then.
I was like 94.
But my point was that at one point in time,
the executive producer,
he actually said to me,
he goes,
why are you still doing standup?
You're an actor now.
Yeah,
they don't.
People don't get that.
People think that when you do stand up,
it's to make it.
Yeah.
And you're like,
oh.
And then when you make it,
you're like,
you did it dude,
you graduated.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what that's you though.
That's your job.
That's you.
That to me,
that's what like that's why I say when I don't understand,
when comedians who have a show apologize for some shit they did.
Right.
Because it's like that's in a way that's disrespecting who you are,
unless you really feel bad about yourself.
Of course,
if you're like,
yeah,
you know,
I mean I,
whatever,
whatever it is is a fuck this.
Fuck that.
And then you're like,
oh well I shouldn't have said that and you mean that and you feel bad then fine.
But,
but the thing is that we're,
you know,
to be a comedian means your somebody who people are going to go to see jokes and
if you are telling jokes and that somebody gets
offended and then you say you're sorry,
I,
I didn't mean that.
I shouldn't have said that.
Then what you're saying is you're kind of serious.
You were kind of serious onstage when he said that.
Yeah,
exactly.
To just be like,
well,
no,
I'm not sorry because I was joking and I'm sorry you feel that way,
but I,
I'm not sorry for making a rape joke or whatever because it was a joke.
I was trying to fucking be funny.
Right.
That's why the only thing worse than what,
uh,
was that Michael Riche,
Michael Richards,
when that was terrible,
that was,
did not seem like a joke at all.
It seemed real as fuck.
Well,
we didn't around back then.
I was,
I was like an open Mike or at the Aha cafe when that shit happened.
So,
and I kind of knew Frazier Smith a little bit because he was who he was,
who was hosting that night,
you know,
and I was like,
oh wow.
Frazier was hosting that night.
And,
um,
and uh,
and when that happened,
when you saw that,
like there's nobody in the right mind that would have seen what went down with
Michael Richards onstage and being like,
oh no,
he was joking around.
Well,
Michael bitches is the exact opposite because Michael Richards started out as an
act,
got super fast,
and then tried to be a comedian.
Right,
right.
That's,
that's tough.
That's real fucking tough.
That's way harder.
It's way fucking harder.
You know who Charlie Murphy did that too?
Oh,
he did?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Charlie Murphy was an actor for his entire career,
then gone on Chappelle show.
And then when he was on Chappelle show,
everybody wanted him to do standard.
Right.
And then he started doing standup,
like a headline.
Wow.
That's,
I can't fucking imagine that he's got balls.
Charlie Murphy has giant fucking iron balls.
I don't,
I,
you know,
I don't know him,
but,
um,
but yeah,
Michael Richards.
But,
but what happened with Michael Richards would then,
when he went on to Letterman to do apologize,
it was even worse.
Yeah.
I mean,
he was talking about the war in Iraq.
It was like,
dude,
just say you're sorry,
or whatever.
But,
and then he called and then he said something he called black people blacks,
which just sounds,
you're like,
yeah,
you're so out of touch.
Just a blast blast.
It was just,
it was just all you had to do was be like,
Yo,
I was,
look,
we've all been in that situation as a comedian where something goes wrong and
you're like,
and you,
and you push the envelope and sometimes it works out and sometimes it doesn't.
Like I remember one time a lady mouth off at me and the audience and I called
her con a bunch of times.
Okay.
Whether or not I,
I feel like I should have done that.
Uh,
the point is,
is,
um,
you're up there fighting for your fucking life,
man.
And if you fuck up,
so be it.
You're,
this is a safe place.
You're a comedian and you're an entertainer.
And if they,
if they try to fuck with you,
you're just kind of fighting for your life and your,
and if somebody were to have seen that and say,
oh Chris Delea called a woman a con out of context,
that sounds fucking terrible.
But I was trying to be funny about it,
you
know?
Yeah.
So to just,
I can't imagine,
I mean God,
his apology was so bad.
It was so bad.
It's also,
you're trying to figure out how to get out of a situation on the flop.
Right?
Like when Michael Richards onstage,
the,
the scenario was Michael Richards was onstage and these guys were heckling him
and Michael Richards,
look,
he was a bad comedian.
He don't even know his stuff at all.
I never knew.
I never saw it.
I saw it live in the flesh.
He was terrible.
He would go on stage and everyone would be waiting for the funny stuff to start.
Cause he's so funny aside though,
cause he's Seinfeld Kramer,
he goes on stage and he would like do these pratfalls and stumbled or just does
this work,
right?
And even work,
he would do all this crazy shit and they would fall down.
It would slip and,
and it would be,
you know,
kind of like silly.
Like you had thought that it was going to set up some common.
Got It.
But it never did.
It would never,
it would never go anywhere.
And so he said the laugh factory and it's like a Friday night and it's late.
It's a weekend night,
it's late.
And uh,
he's fucking bombing and these guys are heckling right.
They're heckling them brutally.
And he just pointed them and starts calling them niggers.
Look,
there are some nigger,
there's a nigger over there.
Whoa.
And I'm,
he was Jesus.
But the backstory is he was on stage at the comedy store before that he went and
did a spy the store and then did a spot at the factory and he was coked out of
his board on stage at the store.
Oh,
I don't even know about this.
Yeah.
Well,
he,
he definitely enjoys stimulants.
You know,
I guess that's not surprising or not.
He absolutely does cocaine.
Can I prove that in court?
No,
I tend not.
I'm just speculation was that he was coked out of his head.
Right.
But then he was like super aggressive and confident on stage for no reason.
That's great.
Cocaine confidence,
you know,
let me bet.
And it was apparently it's just,
it was ugly and,
but he got through it without saying nigger.
Right,
right.
We went across the street,
went home.
She could get away without saying they onward.
If he didn't do that,
set me think about that.
His life would be insanely different.
He would,
he could,
he would still be doing stand up.
Who would have sitcoms.
He would be beloved.
People would take your meetings with them.
They'd be excited to see him in a movie.
You know,
cause it was starting to fail though.
It was all starting to fall apart on him.
Stand up will expose you if you're not a stand.
Oh yeah.
It'll expose the shit out of you and you have to keep sharp too.
It's like people are like,
when you know,
my favorite,
one of my favorite hours is Eddie Murphy.
You know,
and people were like,
he should come back.
You should come back,
dude.
If could you imagine coming back after 30 years of not doing it and getting
busted with transsexual hookers?
We'd have to talk about it.
But unless you're Jim Norton and you can just completely own it,
most people can't completely own weird perverted shit.
Especially when you're a giant.
That's why you can't
apologize if you're a yeah.
That's why.
Unless you really did a Kramer,
you know,
unless you,
unless you truly feel like you fucked up.
What hey should could have done is he could have said,
listen,
I got a cocaine problem,
and I don't know if you've ever gotten cocaine,
but cocaine makes an idea.
Seem like a good idea.
That's a terrible idea.
Even people who don't do cocaine know that they're aware that he's like,
look,
I,
you know,
I got on stage and I was under the influence and I was bombing.
Here's the deal.
I'm not that good at comedy.
Right.
Okay.
I'm a good comedic actor.
Right.
But as a standup,
I'm marginal at best.
I mean,
if he owned it,
he had said that it would have been like,
oh,
okay.
I get what people forgot about it.
Yeah.
They really would have.
I believe that.
I think,
you know,
at the very least he would have gained a lot of people's respect because it
would have been like hours.
Yeah.
Like ours.
Our respect,
big time.
You know,
your peers that Matt didn't matter if he had done a black only show,
like if he had invited only African Americans to come to come back on me,
come back,
watch me get through it.
We were at the store.
I didn't see the spot that he had at the laugh factory,
but we were at the store that night.
I had missed Kramer.
My spot was,
I'm calling them Kramer forever.
Fuck him.
I missed him.
And I had,
uh,
I had gone to the store like just after his spot.
So,
uh,
I got there and they were all talking about how bad he was.
Like,
it's like,
oh Kramer.
So coked up.
And so then we're hanging around in the pocket of the lights were hanging around
in the parking lot and Brent earns,
comes over from the laugh factory and you know Brent,
he was like,
Yo,
you ain't got to fucking believe what just went down to the laugh factory.
And so he starts telling us the whole story about Michael Richard going off and
you know,
and drop it in bombs and the whole deal.
And we were like,
Whoa,
I didn't think anything of it.
And then Monday morning the video came out and then you know,
it was one of the very first of those videos that like catches someone doing
something really fucked.
That's the other thing man,
is that if that wasn't a big thing then and it became a big thing then that was
one where you're saying one of the first times that that happened,
that that is just fucking,
that was when I saw that I was like,
I actually had a thought where it's like,
man,
we live in a different world now.
I mean,
how many times has something like that happened?
Undocumented.
Oh,
or that.
How many times have I done things like that on [inaudible] haven't cause I grew
up in this fucking age.
So it's like you're getting fucked pal.
I know you're not getting fucked as much as 21 year olds are getting fucked.
Like they,
they have no knowledge of any time before this,
you know,
at least you being 34 you can,
I mean you kinda are watching it come to fruition as you're an adult and you're
kind of seeing all these fuck ups happen like the Kramer fuck up and all these
other fuckups seeing them as you were becoming a successful standby.
Ooh,
don't do that.
learn from that guy.
Right.
There is a mistake I don't want to make but these kids like they don't even get
that
like the music spo.
I know,
but then that's the thing we,
we,
there has to be some sort of backlash where it's like,
um,
we're like,
look,
I I think,
I think I'm a good guy.
You know,
I try to,
I try to be good to people.
I think my friends would say that the guy guy for sure.
Well thank you.
But,
but I,
I'm trying to not be braggadocious or even modest.
I'm just trying to like think outside myself and think I think I'm a good
person.
Okay.
And I definitely fuck up.
There's absolutely things out there that if I were to run for a Po for some sort
of office ti,
I will be fucking buried before I've been stuck.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Even if I was really politically minded and very smart and the best candidate,
there's no fucking way I would get elected because I've already done the thing
that buried me and somebody got a screenshot of it.
Yeah.
Do you know what I mean?
But,
so here's the thing though.
I think that we live in a time now where you've got to just like look there.
That shit's out there.
It's videotapes somewhere.
Somebody's got something.
I fall asleep.
Chicks fucking probably take a pictures of me with all the sheets.
I,
my Dick's probably it's been probably is out there somewhere.
Probably.
You just got to be,
somebody's got to come out to the,
we're,
we're where they get exposed and they just have,
and there's a video of the guy,
are you sorry,
did this happen?
What you have to say about this fucking Dick pic?
And you just gotta be like,
look,
you either like me or you don't.
I fuck up.
You fuck up.
There's shit out there like this because of me,
because of my stature and where I am.
And if you like me,
you like me.
And if you don't,
you don't,
then I'm sorry and subscribed to me or don't.
And a lot of it isn't even a fuck up.
I know.
It's not,
let me think about that.
Like if you're like the scenario that you proposed,
if you're lying there and some chick takes a picture of your Dick,
that's not a fuckup man.
Fuck up.
It's not a fuckup that's life.
But,
but,
but if,
uh,
if that happens,
we'll politician.
He doesn't get elected.
That's true.
And that's,
that's fucking bullshit.
Yeah,
it's ridiculous.
That's bullshit.
But I think it's only ridiculous based on the standards of the,
the,
the previous generations.
I think that we're judging these politicians on these previous generation's
standards.
And then as time goes on,
we'll,
we'll look.
Obama is one of the first presidents that said he did coke and smoked weed would
have never happened in the 60s.
You know,
I was,
I've retweeted this thing today was about Nixon.
It's about Nixon during the Watergate administration or during the Watergate
scandal.
Nixon brought in a bunch of generals and was testing the waters for taking over
Congress and having a cool,
having like a military intervention to takeover.
It's really fascinating.
I don't want to,
um,
misquoted or anything,
but
that guy,
like he,
his era was a different era.
Like the,
the Nixon administration's error was a completely different era.
Like his,
the standards that he was judged by was,
was things that there was no one was exposed for anything in the past.
And so all of a sudden he gets exposed to Watergate,
had missed the Watergate scandal,
happens,
he gets busted,
right.
Spying on other candidates.
And then,
you know,
he feels this,
there was also when Kent state happened,
when they shot those kids that were protesting the Vietnam war and he was
constantly worried about lefties constantly worried about liberals and the
liberals taking over the lefties and the east coast lefties.
And he apparently had some crazy meeting with these uh,
these generals.
And this is the one of the,
the guy says,
I got the impression he said that he was sort of testing the water with us to
see whether or not there would be support.
Any nodding of heads or some of these other things.
Uh,
one,
one could well have come to the conclusion that here was the commander in chief
trying to see what the reaction of the Joint Chiefs of staff might be if he did
something unconstitutional.
He was trying to find out whether or not,
uh,
in a crunch there would be support to keep him in power.
So like if they were trying to keep him,
then we're going to kick him out of power because of the Watergate thing.
He was going to bring in the military,
like he was trying to test the waters,
but today and that same sort of scenario,
right?
Like a guy [inaudible] it's over,
you know,
you,
you can't,
you can't hide things.
Like you could hide things.
Then so he got busted and he thought they were going to try to kick him out of
office and like,
you know,
he's a,
Nixon was a really bad guy.
It was a really bad guy,
but they were all really bad guys.
Like I probably,
everybody that was present was a really bad guy and that's how they did it.
I think the standards that people are going to be judged by are going to be very
different because I don't think really bad guys are going to be able to be
present in the future.
I don't think a guy like Nixon,
we'll get to a point where he could be the president and not have all the dirt
on him that would be revealing,
illuminated,
but long before he ever got an office,
there's that.
It has to be that way.
Yeah,
there's good to that.
And there's bad because the good thing is a guy like Nixon,
like there'd be enough on him before he ever got into office that no one would
accept him.
Right,
right.
Yes.
Yeah,
totally.
But like the stuff,
like the sexual stuff that people do,
you know,
like,
like JFK wouldn't ever been president.
Right.
Never.
Never,
never chance if there,
if there was Facebook back when JFK or direct messages.
I mean,
JFK was an animal.
He was a fucking animal.
He didn't,
didn't care if he was married.
He didn't care.
He was going to party.
He was a goddamn president.
United States,
the commander in chief and he was going to get his dick wet.
That was just it.
He just did it.
That's so crazy.
And a president today,
no chance.
Clinton was the last guy,
the last of the Great Presidential Dick.
Slingers.
That's it.
From now on,
you'll be judged and it's a completely different way.
I don't know if that's,
I don't,
you know,
is that good?
Well,
it's not,
it's good when it comes to things that aren't sexual because that affects the
job.
Yes.
But it's not fair to judge somebody's sexual prowess because of,
uh,
you say prowess.
Is it prowess or is it practices?
Here's the thing,
it's not,
but is it because what if instead of like sex,
what if it was a gambling thing?
Right.
What if he had this crazy gambling thing,
right.
Where you found out that,
you know,
hey man,
Obama can't stop gambling on shit.
He gambles on everything.
Roll the dice to roaches running across the table.
I killed just gamble.
Raindrops coming down a window.
But that,
that arguably does affect a job.
Yeah.
You know,
but I don't know if you wanting to get ass would be like,
you know,
what are we going to do in Gaza?
I don't know what you see that ass like that doesn't feel,
but gambling could affect that.
There was thoughts that the,
the,
one of the things that could affect a president if the president was like a real
pussy chaser was that someone could blackmail him.
That if,
if someone had some information,
like if you say,
if you hire,
I gotcha.
I hired.
Yeah,
sure.
That makes sense.
Soviet spy,
super hot to fuck them to fuck the prison,
some presidential dick and she fucks him.
And then she has some dirt on them.
And so the pillow talk pillow talk's a motherfucker till it talks a
motherfucker.
Um,
yeah,
that's a thing.
But that's kind of more,
I mean,
is that really a thing?
I don't think so.
I mean,
come on.
I don't know what hot chick around the W.
I mean,
what?
You know what I mean?
Come on.
What happens in movies?
I'm like,
come on James Bond.
Yes.
Yeah.
First of all,
there's no hot spy.
There must be to be to,
to,
to make it,
to make it took for that instance,
right?
I mean to be like,
we have to get you into,
he's just going to chase it.
Top 10 beautiful lady spies.
Let me tell you something.
Let me do some right now.
Pull.
The nine of them are not hot.
Nine of them are not hot.
10 of them are not hot.
They're all disgusting.
Whoa.
Wait til you see these monsters.
Actually,
I'll take that back.
Then one of them start getting down.
That's Joey.
There's um,
okay.
And
what's the link from,
um,
just pulled that up.
Just pull that,
that it's a smashing lists.
Top 10 beautiful lady spies from history.
It's the first one also.
You never,
you never there.
There can't be a spy walking down the street where you're like,
damn,
look at that person.
There was a woman,
her name was Anna Chapman.
She was a beautiful 28 year old Russian with Iq of 162
what?
Yup.
She had a diplomatic father,
a diplomat,
father,
and it tastes for the high life.
She's a Russian national.
When living in New York,
United States was arrested along with Gyn.
Others,
the titles the best,
he'll get her.
That's her.
Foreigns no,
it's a monster.
I don't know who she is,
but uh,
this woman,
Anna Chapman is pretty hot.
She's on page two.
Young Jamie,
knowing that other girl was not to know.
Um,
but she um,
she's arrested along with Zack.
Yeah.
It looks kind of how Chapman,
yeah,
she's hot as shit.
She's dirt for sure.
Guaranteed dirty.
Look at those eyes.
That's a,
those are dick soccer.
So she was a spy.
Yes.
Um,
so she was a Russian national while living in New York.
United States was arrested along with nine others on 27th of June,
2010 wow.
Recently on suspicion of working for the illegals program,
spy ring under the Russian federations,
external intelligence agency,
um,
Chapman pleaded guilty to a charge of conspiracy to act as an agent of a foreign
government without notifying the u s attorney general and was deported back to
Russia.
That's it.
Just deported as a part of prisoner swap.
And right now she's tied to a bed somewhere in Russia.
Just fucking
wonder what she's doing today,
Dan.
My bitches up.
Woo.
Yeah.
Then the next one,
number four.
Number five.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well that's about it.
Well,
this is an Asian one and they're number three.
That's pretty hot.
Young,
beautiful female spy during the Chinese civil war between Blah,
blah,
blah.
Can't even,
I can't even read that.
That K,
u o m I n t [inaudible] Tang and the communist party,
she was only 15.
She was only 15.
He should put that part up.
42 to 1947 wines.
No,
that's,
that's the,
no,
that's when the image,
wait,
what,
see right here is the whole birth.
I'm confused.
That's a ridiculous,
but,
but 19 is not that old.
That's confusing.
Cause his 1932 32 to 1947,
what does that mean?
I don't know.
That's a still from a did she die?
Maybe
she must've back in the Oh,
the life and death of her has become a symbol of the courage of the Chinese
people is often cited as a homily.
H O m I l y of their Lord.
I don't even know that word is what's homily?
I don't know.
I've never heard that word used.
Okay,
let's Google it.
I love the Internet.
What a weird world we live in.
[inaudible] homily is,
um,
a religious discourse that is intended primarily for spiritual edification
rather than doctrinal and struggle.
Oh fuck.
Are you using that word for,
of their loyalty to communism?
Her story is often told as
an homage to this struggles endured and the sacrifices made for the cause of
liberating China from the centuries of rule by foreign powers.
Okay.
That's one of those words that he uses.
Other words,
I don't know to describe it.
Okay.
This is a picture of this other chick that's clearly not a real picture.
Number two,
because she was from 1551 you fucks,
right?
You can't have pictures of this check from the 15th goddammit.
Sons of bitches and he's somebody draw nigh and then Mata Hari Mata,
Hari.
That was in 1877 yeah,
but that sounds like some old,
old way of thinking to be like,
well we can't have a president that wants to fuck a lot because a spiraled get
them like,
come on.
It is kind of ridiculous that,
that sounds like that sounds ridiculous.
But we kind of proved our own point because the top 10 throughout history,
we only found one.
One of them was 15 one of them was legitimately hot and like I said,
she was Russian.
Right.
That's it.
So you're saying what?
There was one hot,
right.
So we kind of proved our point.
It's not really worried about,
yeah.
But all throughout human history,
there's only been 10 months.
She was 28 what is she now?
This is,
well now she's still hot.
She still had,
this was only four years ago.
Yeah,
so she's 32
32 out there.
[inaudible]
she was already caught so she's fucked.
Yeah.
We know about her now.
Maybe.
Maybe she got a raise,
you know in Russia they brought it back to Russia.
She probably got damn hero.
Yeah.
Where is she today?
Let's find if that were really a thing.
I think people would,
I mean maybe we don't know about it,
but people would be like raising hot spies.
That's true.
I mean that they're wire.
There's no way we wouldn't do that too.
She's even hotter than that picture.
There's like,
if you go to Google images,
Woo.
Yeah,
she was smoking.
Look at this part can be a maximum.
Oh yeah,
totally.
She sees from,
that's from stuff magazine.
Yeah.
She's got these long red gloves on and his hot lingerie.
Look at this one.
Yeah,
look at,
by the way,
if you're a spy,
don't take fucking pictures like that.
This whole thing doesn't make sense to not be a spy dude.
She's pretending just be hot,
but just stay out of the fucking light.
Okay.
Come on son.
Look at that.
That's really,
really sexy.
I mean,
come on.
Not a spy to it.
Should the picture should say under it.
Not a spy.
Hold it right up to her head while a banger or dirty girl.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
There's a lot of dirty pictures of her.
Somebody should've known.
Yeah,
she was on maxim.
Yeah.
See,
she was on Russian maximum.
Right.
It's like not really maximum.
Yeah.
Mixing.
Don't really count,
but rush.
I'm mix him.
Yeah.
Wonder where she's at today.
Let's see.
Anna Chapman today.
I bet she's got a good gig somewhere in Russia.
She's probably got a podcast.
She probably does one show explaining
how she twic stupid American just by dressing sexy.
Yeah,
she refuses to discuss it.
Okay.
Oh,
like a true spot.
Refuses to die,
Huh?
Interesting.
Pretty well,
but she's connected somehow to Edward Snowden.
Oh Wow.
There was a recent tweet proposing marriage to Edward Snowden.
That's real.
Yeah.
She proposed marriage to Snowden.
I want him to marry me so I can double spy.
Spy on Medica from Russia.
I spy a again and again and again.
I'm a very private,
discreet person on average.
She's on Twitter and many interview.
Is she on Twitter?
I thought she just said,
yeah.
You said there was a tweet about it.
She's kind of a Twitter page.
That's what,
yeah,
but I thought like maybe like somebody else put it.
Oh,
got it.
That's fine.
Now,
Anna Chapman,
Twitter spars need to work on their social networking
and the Chapman on Twitter to tweet alibis.
You can tweet alibis,
put up a twit pic.
Why are you somewhere else?
Yup.
If I went to her Twitter page and she followed me,
I would panic,
but I'm following her.
Or you're blocked?
Nope.
Have you ever gone to someone's page and find out you were blocked and like,
oh,
shit.
No,
no,
no.
Um,
are you astounded by,
uh,
like the,
the,
like social media is become very strange and uh,
like Twitter and,
oh,
everything on her page is all in Russian.
This is kind of wild.
Yeah.
But yeah,
she's a free and clear.
Okay.
All sexy pictures all over the place.
Um,
like a Instagram you go to like you,
you had a funny poem late you like,
how are you a girl and your Instagram page and you don't have 100,000 followers.
How's that happen?
I went to a girl's page and it was just her doing yoga.
It was her ass like her and yoga jeans.
She had 2 million followers on Instagram.
Yeah,
I was walking by in,
I was in Las Vegas or some shit,
I don't know.
And there was a poster,
it was like,
come see Instagram sensation,
Yada Yada.
And it was just some chick.
That's crazy man.
Girls are raised to be a tens on Instagram than in real life.
Oh yeah,
they would because they just won't show up the shit.
I want the followers.
And then you get the followers for having an ass.
And let me ask you something and then what and then what?
That's a good question because there was an article in like one of those New
York magazines that was all about this woman who was an Instagram fitness
sensation.
Sure.
It was just,
they didn't say it,
but it was just because she had a fence.
Udacity.
Yeah,
sure.
It was just incredible.
Right.
They were just talking about her lovely figure.
It's on her figure.
It's her big juicy fireable Boudin and uh,
they were talking about all these projects that they're putting together and
there was a media team behind her and they were going to marketer how fucking
cause of an ass.
Yeah.
Just because of a body part,
a big fleshy body part that carries a lot of,
and that the hips so that you could give birth easy and fat so that you could
sustain the pregnancy and that's fine.
But then when a girl posted a picture of her from behind and it's like,
you know,
some quote inspiration shit and you're just like,
no,
I'll,
I know they have millions of comments on their fucking thing,
but I'll still comment.
No,
I will.
You'll just say,
no,
100% know.
All right.
Because it's not,
it's not okay.
It's not okay.
You can do it,
but then you're an asshole.
There's nothing funnier than when you go to a girl's page or whether it's
Instagram or Twitter,
and there's just a plethora of images of her and sexy positions.
Their ass out in her underwear and Bikini's doing selfies it,
and then there's a quote about men needing to respect boundaries.
That's,
yeah,
that's something that's just like,
no,
the treating women like women,
like a sex object.
You're crazy that that would be like,
if I fucking,
that will be like,
if I took a bunch of peanut butter,
put it all over my eyes and face and mouth and then said to you,
dude,
why does it fucking tastes like peanut butter in here?
You'd be like,
well,
you got fucking Pete.
You will give in.
Say it.
You'd be like,
oh,
you're crazy.
So why don't we fucking say that about those girls?
Well,
we do kind of,
but then when we do,
we're sexist.
Yes.
Well there's also,
you have no hope of fac of banging them then.
If you're a guy that true.
I don't know.
I mean it depends how probably,
right.
You're probably right if you shoot them down and then a million other guys or a
bombing on them,
those,
you know what?
You know what?
Those guys are fucking worse than those girls and those guys are traders.
They are trader sons of bitches.
No,
but for real,
when it do,
it's like,
hey I or when you're,
when you're,
when you're trying to,
you know,
kick it with a girl and then some other dudes like,
Yo,
I heard that dude's bad dude.
Are you?
Oh yeah,
that's the best I heard that dude.
He just fucking,
you know,
he's just out for pussy isn't even carry a lot of girls.
You know what?
That dude usually did helped you by the way.
Yeah.
Cause she's not going to be like,
Oh really?
By,
she's not going to do that.
She's going to be like,
hmm,
I think I still know better.
That is a weird thing that dude's do.
What do you do that some dudes,
I would never do that.
As a matter of fact,
I've been wanting,
I've been trying,
like if I'm like really trying to get this girl and she's so hot or whatever,
and then I,
and,
and I find out she has a boyfriend and there's been situations in my life where
I was like,
oh,
I found out a girl had a boyfriend and I found out that the is cheating.
I would never fucking that that's them.
That's their thing.
Yeah.
To be a fucking dude.
This gonna be like,
dude,
I think I'm going to do the right thing,
but really just doing it because of the Instagram asks,
you're a fucking asshole.
Well,
there's a lot of dudes that are fake white nights.
They're just trying to look good,
just trying
to come off as like,
I'm different than men.
I have ethics and morals and they're really important to me.
They're just trying to position themselves.
If you're a dude and your best friend is a woman,
it's,
uh,
it's suspect.
It's suspect.
It's very suspect.
Highly suspect.
Yeah.
Unless she's really unusual.
Well look,
there are,
look,
and I'm not saying that women and hot women and whoever are,
I mean they're fucking good.
They can be great friends,
but you all,
if they're hot and even if they're not,
you sometimes still wanna.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
And that's okay.
Right.
You know the guys that do have like a hot woman,
that's the best friend that they're not banging and they'd pretend now it's just
totally platonic.
Like,
okay,
I could never trust that guy unless he has like an insanely hot wife that,
that yeah.
Or if they used to date,
yes.
That's possible.
If they like legitimately have nothing to do with each other anymore.
Right.
Like I have x's that like I wouldn't want her to sleep with,
but in they're hot.
You know what I mean?
Right.
It's stover.
Yeah,
it's over.
But you're still friends.
Yeah.
Friendly and did not your best shit.
Fucking weird.
That's weird.
What's weird when anybody,
like when a guy is like working on an angle and trying really hard to like
position himself as better than he positioned himself as being like different
than every other guy.
You know,
and there's a lot of guys out there to doing really negative things.
Like I read this one guy's fucking Twitter page of the day.
It was amazing.
It was just like,
he's,
he might be the ultimate White Knight.
I don't want to give out his Twitter page,
but he,
he might be like the greatest if I met him,
he probably has almost no blood in his veins.
He says,
blood sugar is probably zero.
You probably faints all day long.
But
it was so weak.
But one of the things he said is,
he said,
all,
although I still practice feminists,
uh,
still practice feminism,
I no longer associate I no longer w what'd you say?
Advertise myself as a feminist because I feel like it's up to women to decide
whether or not I'm doing feminism correctly.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
So I'll still practice feminism,
but I will no longer advertise myself as a feminist.
Jesus Christ.
Got It.
That's a,
I actually don't even know what to say about that.
Male feminism is a very strange thing.
Not male
wallet,
it specialists or equality promoters,
specialist egalitarian people who only look out for the greater good of all
humanity and don't gender identify or don't.
They're not,
they're not gender specific in how they think that people should rights.
And actually that's,
I think equality is a beautiful thing.
I mean,
when it comes to like how people were treated and when it comes to laws and
without a doubt that's how it should be.
But this idea of male feminism,
it strikes me as a bit pandering.
There's a little bit of pandering going on.
There's a little bit of a absolutely.
A little bit of role playing going on.
Absolutely.
Well,
yeah,
because because a male has it in them to want to sleep with women.
If so,
it's like that's not going away.
This guy,
just because you respect a woman doesn't mean you can't see a woman and be like,
Damn,
look at that ass.
Right.
Okay.
That's what those guys are acting like.
Like that,
that,
no,
I'm not,
I'm better than that.
I don't look at her as an object.
You have,
you have a midbrain.
What's a midbrain?
What will your midbrain is like?
You're reacting like a lizard.
You know what I mean?
You're like,
yeah,
of course it'll read fast.
Red Car goes by.
He's like,
well shit,
you,
even if you don't physically do that,
you fucking,
well you,
you,
you will notice it,
right?
You can be fucking a girl,
a beautiful girl.
And then on the TV,
a commercial comes on with a beautiful girl and you'll be like,
who's that?
Yes.
You could be.
And we're not supposed to acknowledge that.
Well,
yeah,
I know.
I don't think this about that.
I think with them it's,
it's about positioning themselves as being what women have a problem with men in
the same way that men have prom with women,
like what,
what,
what are the issues that men have a problem with women?
All right,
and this is just some men and some women.
These are generalizations,
but there's always like,
oh,
that girl's a gold digger.
She just wants a rich guy.
She wants a guy with a big Dick,
she wants some big stud,
some big ape,
you know,
she doesn't even realize,
and I'm the guy for her.
These like issues that a lot of men have with women,
right?
And a lot of women,
the issues they have with men is,
oh,
he's an animal.
The guy's a savage.
He's just trying to fuck a bunch of women.
He doesn't ever want to settle down.
He doesn't want to ever have a family.
He's never going to be loyal to one woman.
And so men will position themselves as being different than every other man.
They'll come along and they'll say,
I've seen the,
the evil of,
you know,
Male,
uh,
you know,
patriarchal behavior.
And I just think it's not cool.
I'm a feminist.
I'm basically looking out for all women's rights and I'm different than all
women.
What you don't ever find is men who,
well,
I guess you could find,
but it's very rarely guys who were savages who identify with being a feminist.
Like,
it's not like I don't,
I Studley athletic,
you know,
pro football players,
like little muscle,
a feminist.
Right.
Basically,
you know,
it sounds funny.
It's guys that are like,
they're not very manly and so their,
their shtick is I'm going to position myself as being the solution to all these
other men that are out there.
I'm socially retarded.
I don't,
I'm not attractive in the traditional sense.
So when I'm going to do is just be like super ultra sensitive and super aware of
women's needs and super attentive and I'm just going to live my life in misery
and attempt and I guess that works sometimes.
Got have fucking platinum albums.
Do they though?
Who are you thinking of?
Like which guy?
I don't guys don't get a guitar and just be like,
but those guys get mad pussy.
Well that,
that's what I'm saying.
Like John Mayer.
Let's about that.
I don't know,
but he's not a feminist.
That's true.
But if that guy's just,
he's constantly got a new girlfriend in the picture.
Yeah,
I guess you're right.
I guess shit.
Right.
Then maybe those guys don't know that he's more like a romantic,
right,
right.
Like,
you know,
he's positioning himself as well.
But I mean look,
people position them.
So like what,
what,
what do we do as comedians?
I mean,
one of the reasons why guys got into comedy,
I know one of the reasons what I loved about doing comedy,
he's all sudden girls liked me.
Like they didn't like me when I was a fighter.
I was,
it was very rare that girls were really excited to hang out with some guy who
was hanging out with sweaty dudes all day getting kicked in the face.
And it's not that attractive but me and gets here a famous fighter.
But,
but,
but comedians like they,
you can make them laugh and so you would,
you would work hard on being more funny,
be more funny around girls to get girls to like you.
I mean,
pretty much every comedian that's heterosexual has had that motivation be
funnier because girls like funny guys.
Yeah.
And when do you feel less attractive?
You ever taken a girl to a show and you ate dick on stage?
Cool.
Well,
that's a terrible,
terrible,
terrible place to be because then you have,
then you have nothing.
You have what you thought was going to work and it's worked.
It's laughing.
You're like,
oh,
she should have just youtube to me.
But it's even worse because she,
you know,
you're,
you're worse than a guy who does nothing because what you do,
you're awful at.
It's not like I'm trying to find my place in this life,
but I've got good features.
No,
right.
He's made,
he's got potential lunch.
Chris gets his shit together.
But no,
you bomb on stage.
Like they saw what you do and you do it awful.
That's really fucking funny.
But you're positioning yourself as like being a funny guy.
You'll like,
hey,
you know,
I'm the guy.
You want to come to me for labs.
Some people are not that guy there.
The guy you want to come to me for your quality talk.
I know a lot about women's rights and I don't,
I used to identify as a feminist,
but I found that like insulting to actual women.
So I no longer identify as a feminist.
I will leave it up to women to decide whether or not I'm doing feminism
correctly.
Yeah.
Amazing.
If that guy picked up a box of cookies,
he would fall asleep in the middle of lifting it up.
It would fall and hit his head and
outside the shit hits the fan.
That guy's not going to be able to rebuild.
Society has to be a singer that said,
oh,
I think he's a comedian.
You don't even know.
That's the funny.
It's whatever it is.
It's a disaster.
It's,
it's a bunch of people,
his shitty friends and like no one pulls him aside.
He goes,
no man,
no,
no on these fuckers Instagram and just
do it and tag me in it so I can find that motherfucker.
He ain't go no.
It.
Matter of fact,
find these dudes on Instagram.
I know a lot of you listen,
find these dudes,
these,
these bitch made dude's on Instagram.
Pic.
You comment,
you comment.
No.
And you tag at Crystal Leah and I want to see these duets.
Yeah,
so I can laugh.
Well,
women position themselves as being different than other women too.
Like Amy Schumer's got a funny fucking sketchy.
She did our show about that,
about the girl who can hang.
It's like there's a girl like,
hey,
I played.
Yeah,
she's hilarious.
It's like,
Hey guys,
I love sports.
You know,
God,
you know,
bitches are a fucking pain in the ass.
Tired of bitches.
Oh hang out with you guys.
And they'll position themselves as being different.
Right.
Then all these other women that want a certain thing from a guy,
you know,
like I,
I knew this one chick and she had no female friends like nun,
but she was t f all day.
She would down to fuck everybody.
And that was her thing that she all had all male friends and you know,
she had boyfriends and she always banged other dude's was,
she had boyfriends.
I mean this chick was just always right,
but that was her hustle.
Her Hustle was that she was,
you know,
one of the guys,
and that's how she got all these guys to like,
and she sorta morphed,
you know,
I mean kind of,
that's kind of what she liked.
But really when you get to know her,
which she really wanted was like a real steady relationship.
And,
but guys,
she'd gotten in that trap where guys didn't take her seriously because sure she
was banging guys while she had other boyfriends and it was always like,
chaos and what does the cigarette,
I gotta get Outta here.
I gotta go home late.
You know,
people,
they get in that position where their whole life is like a constant,
I'm late.
I got to go fuck my life.
Fuck my life.
That was this check.
She was just,
it was always like,
oh,
Bobby thinks I'm fucking Stephen.
She's like,
it's all bullshit,
Stephen.
I've been friends for years.
I told him,
well,
are you fucking Stephen?
I've been fucking Steve.
And we went to college together.
It's like,
not even,
it's like,
see,
I mean,
it's like,
you know,
he comes over and sometimes they're both horny and you're like,
oh my God,
you're crazy.
But her hustle was,
she was different than all the other girls.
She was like just one of the guys she could hang and cheap.
But she deep down inside wanted a committed relationship course,
but no guy who wanted to give it to her.
Well,
not if she's fucking all of his friends.
People Morph,
man.
They morph and become who they think that other people want them to be.
That's true.
You know,
whether it's they become a male feminist or the weather it become a down ass
bitch or whatever,
you know,
people and then along the way,
they actually are that person along the way.
They actually become now.
That becomes all they know of themselves.
Yeah.
Well it's cause that's what they're,
you know,
it's like Oj probably thinks he didn't kill his wife.
You know what?
Everything so,
well,
I dunno.
I mean I wonder,
I don't know.
That's what they say,
but it's like the mind is fucking insane.
You make yourself who you want to be.
I think it's totally possible that he really believes at this point.
I don't know if he does or did,
you know,
it doesn't completely possible though.
I mean,
people have been way crazier than that.
Right.
Oh yeah.
That's just crazy.
It's not super duper crazy.
Crazy.
No,
it's not.
Yeah.
I mean,
if you lie to yourself for fucking 10 15,
what does it 20 years now?
93 94 or something like that.
Yeah,
20 years.
Yeah.
20 fucking years.
God,
that flew by almost 20 years.
Yeah.
People,
they become like religious people.
Think about how many religious people have like almost the exact same way of
talking,
almost the exact same inflection.
Like how many late night preachers have the same way of talking.
They all talk about God's word in the same way,
the same way Chris Delea.
So we're,
Jesus came down with these rules came down from the mountain.
But why is that that they do that?
Because it's something they adopt just like a male feminist adopts sort of an
emo way of tracking in a more subtle way of like,
I'm more like,
I'm less aggressive passive.
I'm like much,
much more people that adopt comedians to go on stage.
And I uh,
yeah.
How many guys?
Like you remember when there was like 10 guys that sounded exactly like David
Tess?
There was like 10 guys there and everybody would just be like,
they were doing a towel.
They would go on stage.
They would do
also with the uh,
sports announcers.
They,
you know,
that's the A,
we go out again,
side retired that when I do that,
you're not like,
oh,
that's that sports announcer.
You're like,
that's the sports announcer guy.
Or like morning zoo Dj's.
Oh,
I did a tour,
one of those radio tours the other day where it was promoting something.
Worst things ever.
Yet they're not the worst things ever,
but dang,
almost like North Korean prison
would be on the list of worst things ever.
Nice folks.
I'm sure they're all,
they're all,
they're all nice individually,
but when you have to do four hours of bed,
it's the worst.
Well,
it's the,
well,
you,
you really appreciate when you call one and it's like,
and they know their shit.
A good dude.
Yeah.
Like,
or a good gal.
Or You're taught how to say it.
Good.
Yeah.
She's a good gal.
It sounds like you're just seeing in salt.
They were super imposed over your face.
She's a good gal.
But you know,
I did four hours of this shit,
you know,
from like 6:00 AM to 10:00 AM and um,
I spoke to 10 people that their exact same person.
I'll ride Chris Delea on the line.
Crystal,
he has new comedy tour starts this week.
Boom,
boom,
ha,
woo.
And then their questions.
So what's the deal?
What do you,
what when I did on dateable and I did these fucking things.
Are you dateable
well,
what,
what is your fear factor?
That's what I used to get.
What are you afraid of?
Cause I'm sure you don't want to eat bugs,
right?
No.
What,
what now what now?
The show's called on datable.
You're a good looking guy,
Chris.
What's the deal?
Just watch the boat.
What's the most uh,
data but what,
what are you find a datable at a girl?
Ooh,
Ooh.
Floating shoes.
Whoa.
Take it out.
Or Strip club Dj come into this stage where Lexus Mercedes on stage to do
gentlemen,
$15 Comma Cassie's.
Alright,
here we go.
Jenna.
Later years he goes,
oh,
I'll give it up for Anastasia
safe next batter.
Yeah.
It's uh,
yeah,
that,
those,
those inflections,
those like patterns that people choose,
they,
they think that like this is how comedians supposed to talk.
I'll talk like that and then I'll be a comedian.
Like I dunno if it you did it,
but um,
a lot of comedians do it when they're starting out.
I had a real problem where I would mimic other comedians and I would catch
myself.
Yeah.
If you watch too much or if you're like,
you know,
in the beginning we were going to be like,
I like that guy,
you know,
and then you go on stage and,
but you figure it out if you do it enough,
you know,
it's like,
it's like reading one author and just siding with him and then you're like,
wait,
there's other books out there.
You've got to read a wall and then come with your own opinion.
Yeah.
You talking about Brian County end,
we were talking about that earlier on.
The fucker look,
get on.
He will read a book and he probably doesn't even read the book and where he's
like one chapter.
It's amazing book.
You,
you have to read this and he basically seekers out life and you're like,
wait a minute,
did you know that guy's crazy?
And I'll start sending him like debug things you that guy disagrees with Nobel
prize winning scientist and he misquotes their work and I'll send him like all
this fucking Brian and I got in this huge argument once because he kept quoting
this asshole that he had on his podcast.
So in the middle of the conversation,
cause I saved this my phone cause I was tired of having this conversation with
them.
I just start reading off all the different things where this guy has lied and
said things wrong and you see him slowly get deflated.
I go,
do you ever just,
just Google debunked after that guy,
just whatever guy you have.
Yes,
I do that with everybody.
I do that with everybody now that I have as a guest,
I had this one guy on named Dave Asprey and this guy,
he's a nice nice guy.
He's a little ass burglary and uh,
he,
he said a bunch of shit is going to want to have him on in the first place.
I didn't know.
I don't know.
I don't mean that.
I mean what was the reason he was on the,
she said knowledgeable guy knows a lot of shit.
About what though?
Like what different,
like he calls himself a biohacker.
And how did you know,
learn about him?
I think Tate Tate Fletcher turned me into,
I'm pretty sure,
pretty sure it was Tate Tate loves a,
He created this,
um,
we didn't create it,
but he popularized this idea of a mixing coffee with grass fed butter and MCT
oil.
So it's like a slow burn of the caffeine gets,
it's a delicious beverage.
That's really all it is.
But along the way,
he started promoting this type of coffee that he has.
That's what's called micro toxin free.
This is a long story that has been beaten to death on his podcast.
So I don't want to go ahead too much.
But after that guy,
it was so much misinformation that I felt responsible for it because I put it
out cause I,
and I repeated the things that he had told me.
So now I Google debunked.
I just,
you know,
eat a lot of times when you Google debunked,
you find out a bunch of fucking crazy people.
Don't even a guy like if you Google me debunked,
you'll find out that I'm like a CIA disinformation agent who is hiding the truth
about chem trails and for real.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's a lot of people that believe that I'm a dis information ancient and then
I'm hiding the truth about chem trails,
chem trails,
which are the evil spraying that the government does with planes.
When you see those contracts behind planes,
those are artificial clouds.
Chris Taleah and those are things
that government,
yeah,
people are out of their fucking mind.
They,
they,
I've been called a paid disinflation agent.
Like they believe that I get paid.
Like I'm waiting for my fucking checks.
First of all,
I'm not getting any checks from getting paid.
It might be a lump sum at the end of my life.
Yeah,
but people,
if you don't believe in the things that they believe in,
they automatically assume that you're a government agent.
I Guy,
this guy,
Mick West who was on the podcast who he was on my Scifi show too,
he runs this site called Metta bunk and it's all about debunking conspiracy
theories and all people ever say she works for the government.
This guy works for the government.
Of course,
he's a multi multimillionaire who sold a video game company as super successful
video game company was a part of the video game company that makes like Tony
Hawk videos and shit,
but dude's loaded and just he's into conspiracies like he's a scientist
essentially and a lot of ways he's not,
I wouldn't say he,
he's a guy who's very educated and intellectually curious and so he tries to
figure out what it is about people that makes them gravitate towards these
unlikely scenarios that they believe that the government is spraying chemicals
in the sky.
And all you hear about this guy is that he's a paid disinformation agent,
which I know not to be true.
I know it's that true.
Right.
But people want to believe that kind of shit.
Yeah,
it's more,
it's more exciting if there's like big secrets out there certainly is.
Do you think you,
do you ever hear that shit and you're like,
I mean like I don't know Dick about that stuff,
you know,
so when I hear like,
like there's a part of me that doesn't believe,
even though I know it has happened for sure they've covered stuff up like I
think like to come on,
they can't do that shit of the world is when we talked about earlier the Nixon
story that's out that I tweeted today,
that's a perfect example of the,
there is fuckery in the world.
Like Nixon tested the waters of like trying to see if there's any support for
military Coogan's congress.
That stuff does happen.
Look,
Watergate did happen.
They did spy on people that did record.
Um,
Kent State did have,
they did hire that they meet did take the national guard and make them break up
student protests and shoot students,
shoot American students nonviolent non armed.
They did that,
you know,
they,
they did.
There's a lot of shit that's been done.
So I think conspiracies are real.
But I think that the problem is that most people don't go into any scenario with
an open mind.
They don't really try to find out all the facts.
They have a predetermined idea that they want to,
they want that conclusion to be,
you know,
they want it to be valid.
They want to validate their conclusion more than they want to objectively look
at the truth.
Yeah,
that's a fucking huge problem.
Yeah.
Oh it's huge problem.
Well like look,
here's another thing like say we were talking about like you're a good guy,
right?
But if somebody wanted to find dirt on you,
if they wanted to dig deep,
you are the president.
They could find something fucked up about you.
Well in finding that fucked up thing about you,
that one fucked up thing.
They could decide what Christa,
Leah,
he got drunk,
wants a jerked off in this girl's hair and he fucking asshole.
They could decide he is a chronic masturbator in girls' hair while they're
drunk.
Like this is what he does.
It's all he does is this his whole life.
Everything else is just setting himself up so he could jerk off people's hair
like,
like they could decide that one thing that you've done,
you made sure you are.
Yeah.
Is We wore all the time.
They'll find one aspect of the personality that you know,
like maybe you did this once or maybe you ran a red light and they'll just say,
he's a fucking reckless driver.
We've got runner show,
red light runner.
This guy's an asshole.
Did you see this Tony Stewart thing?
Do you know what?
Know what happened?
Ran over a guy,
he's a NASCAR driver and he ran over guy.
We were talking about it on the way home and um,
we were driving home from the Jolla.
We did a,
the La Jolla San Diego this weekend.
Did American comedy and as we were driving back,
um,
it was right when it was breaking,
right?
Yup.
And uh,
Tony Stewart,
who's this big time NASCAR driver,
ran over a guy in this dirt race with,
what are those called?
Sprint.
Sprint car,
I think Brent car,
they ride,
they,
this is crazy cars,
that weird looking cars.
They have wings on them and they drive around the dirt and he hit this guy's
car.
The guy got out of the car and was yelling at Tony Stewart and Tony Stewart ran
him over with his car.
It's really fucked up.
He meant to do it.
See that's where things get weird.
He says,
absolutely not.
Of course the uh,
the,
the local cops,
w whoever investigated it,
they're not pressing charges.
They think it was a total accident.
But now because of that,
everybody starts pulling up all the different shit that this guy's done right.
Past drive,
of course,
because apparently he's bumped people's cars before.
He's a very aggressive driver and there's been a lot of aggressive drives.
I,
I'm completely new to this stuff.
I don't follow racing,
but Tony Hinchcliffe does.
And Hinchcliffe was the one that told me that Tony Stewart is known for being
this like really super aggressive driver.
So now I'm reading all this stuff online and these people are just bringing up
all these times in the past where he's,
he's clipped cars,
he's yelled at people or hit people.
He's,
he's,
you know,
he's a maniac and they're concentrating all on this.
The negative aspects of this guy,
all negative aspects to try.
I mean who,
it,
I don't understand exactly what it is cause they want to believe that he hit,
he hit him on purpose.
They want to believe that he hit the gas when he's near the guy cause he knew
the asset and the car would kick out and the acid in the car kicked out.
The Guy who get run over,
right.
Like it's,
it's just one of those things where when something happens,
if something goes wrong,
people will find the one,
one thing or the APP and then concentrate wholly on that instead of like,
I mean,
this is pure speculation because I don't know exactly what happened.
Instead of,
you know,
maybe he did drive aggressive and knock that guy on the wall and the guy got out
of his fucking car and the guy was on the track yelling at him.
And I don't understand,
I've never raced,
I don't know what it's like,
but I would imagine that there's some really fucking split second decision
going,
flying around a track and you see a guy on the fucking track pointing at you.
Uh,
I would,
I would imagine that the decisions like the pro and con do this and you,
you wouldn't be okay,
do that and that guy's going to die there.
There's such a small window of,
because this guy's
walking around on a fucking restraint.
You're not supposed to get out of your car and walk around.
Right?
But all these people all online,
I've been looking at it all day yesterday.
All of them were saying that he killed this guy.
So many people are blaming him for it.
Well,
that's also the people who write on the Internet though.
That's true.
No,
you know what I mean?
Yeah,
it's true.
But even eye witnesses,
people who were there at the time,
I dunno.
I mean maybe it's not the best example because,
no,
it's a good example.
It definitely is.
I mean,
but there's kind of a lot of evidence that he's a wild man,
you know?
Well that's,
but that's,
but what you're saying is totally different than fucking trying over rationally.
But it could be that he was trying to like bump into him.
Like he was trying to prompt him with his car and instead he asked how fast was
he going?
I don't know.
Probably 25 to 35 he's under caution.
Not even that fast.
It was under caution.
So that's not fast at all.
So you would think at 25 you'd be able to not hit the gun.
I knew for out of the way.
Yeah.
Did he,
did he hit his gas?
They don't know.
That's why people are singing.
Espn maybe muted the audio so you can't hear that.
But there's also a lot of people yelling.
They just muted the audio probably.
And just in general.
Let's watch it.
It's quiet.
It's fucked up to watch cause he know a guy died.
But yeah,
I don't like watching that shit.
You ever watch that faces a death shit.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I watched it when I was a kid and I was like,
Nah,
I can't watch this anymore.
Today kids are so spoiled.
They could just Google murder and just watch a hundred videos where,
where do you even watch that shit?
I don't know.
Live leak live leak.com lively extends scary.
It is scary.
It's Worldstar hip hop plus murder.
Live League is like all the most fucked up things on the Internet.
Like A,
here's the,
let's go full screen in this shit.
So you're going to get with it.
This is going to show the initial accident.
See those cars?
They're like dump trucks.
What are we looking at?
Hand is froze.
Powerful Internet
unfree sorry,
it's on deadspin.
Yeah.
Sometimes it does that when you go full screen,
right?
Yeah.
Get it together to computer.
Just,
I dunno.
Might've lost it.
Why it's got to
beach ball.
They're color wheel.
Yeah.
We've got a beach ball from that.
That's it.
We'll click it off and try again.
Reboot it or a fortune.
It's going to take a long time.
A piece of shit computer.
Why we still out that computer?
Is there any benefit and keep talking about this off the air.
See if you can pull that up though and see.
We could pull it up on another site.
Does allow you to pull another side up,
but that's a NASCAR guy on,
I'll let you if I find it.
Okay.
Yeah.
He's a NASCAR guy,
but that was a nice guy.
Wasn't NASCAR
race.
Well I think those guys that race,
they race and all kinds of shit.
They just,
they got to just sort of like,
just get me in a fucking car.
Looks like us with comedy.
Just give me on a stage somewhere.
Yeah,
like they do.
Crystal is doing a coffee shop.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
He's got an NBC show.
I'll play a laundromat,
I'll do a coffee shop.
I've got to do,
what do you do?
Open mikes show up at like weird spots
and do sets.
Since I started getting into clubs like few years ago and just being able to go
up wherever I want,
I was like,
I just was like,
why would I go play buzz coffee?
You know what I mean?
Why would I go play?
Like,
because it's just like,
because there's going to be,
oh cause there's gonna be an audience at a comedy club.
So go there.
Right.
A real audience.
Yeah.
And,
and I,
you know,
I don't know.
Some of the,
some of these old rooms are fucking awesome.
But then it's like some of them are dog shit,
dog shit.
And they'll,
and they'll pretend they're awesome and then you get to the Gig and they're
like,
oh man,
last week it was great.
I don't know what happened,
how many times you're fucking her dad.
A lot of all rooms are real weird in that like alt rooms that like almost like
everyone's making agreement to put out as little energy as possible.
Yeah.
And then if you come along and you've got,
you're like,
Whoa,
whoa,
what are you doing man?
Yeah.
Don't you knew?
And this is warming room.
What are you trying to be funny?
You're trying too hard to be fun.
Yeah.
You trying.
There was like a,
there is a stigma in alt rooms on trying to entertain.
Yup.
You don't want to try.
Yeah.
I'm trying to though to that idea.
I just say,
write a book,
write a book.
No,
they want you to be on stage and be like that.
But that's guy,
not to me.
I mean,
look,
dude,
fucking some of the all comic,
whatever.
All funny is funny.
I don't give a fuck.
You know,
somebody's all comic is hilarious and some of them are fucking hilarious,
but it's like very few.
All comics,
very few are hilarious.
However,
very few comics are hilarious.
That's true too.
But at all comics,
it's very few.
Very few.
I,
it's been awhile since I've been to one of those.
True,
true all,
you know,
like meltdowns.
Good and shit.
But the,
is that all though?
No,
it's not.
It's not.
It's like Chris Hardwick who's on comedy central.
Right.
It's his thing.
Yeah.
I guess you're right.
You want to fucking hate Koolaid the whole room just fucking run right through
it.
Yeah.
I don't know.
A lot of those all chose,
well,
you put them on,
you put some of those guys up on the comedy store.
It's like death.
It's,
it's uh,
yeah,
it's different.
It's a different show.
Yeah.
Well that's why they,
they built those rooms in the first,
first place.
Right.
That's why those rooms exist.
So that's why I'm saying if you can get into comedy clubs,
get the fucking comedy clubs,
those people are paying to see comedy and it has the word comedy in the fucking
thing.
Comedy Club.
That's what it's for.
Yeah.
It's not fucking,
you know,
buzz coffee is coffee.
Yeah.
Freddy Soto stopped doing those a long time ago before he died.
He,
uh,
he used to tell people like,
they would always ask him,
you know,
hey,
we do my room.
I've got this thing is,
no,
I had a guy,
dude.
Okay.
How many clubs?
I had a guy the other night.
I don't know his name,
but he was like,
you know,
the comedy store,
there'll be like fucking,
you'll be literally like Jim Carrey will show up and then somebody will be like,
Hey,
will you be my documentary?
And you're like,
Whoa,
like just fucking derelicts there.
Do you know what I mean?
I was at a comedy show and I was at the comedy store and then some kid was like,
hey man,
um,
I was wondering if you want to come by and do my room.
And I was like,
oh,
well where is it?
What is it?
He's like,
yeah,
it's this.
Um,
it's,
well,
it's just,
it's on Saturday night and it's just pizza place and um,
you know,
we can't pay you,
but it'd be awesome if you like did 15 minutes and you can have like the Pete
whatever pizza you want.
And I said,
you have to repeat yourself
because I think I heard what you said,
but can you say it?
Can you just say it again?
And he said it again.
And I said,
dude,
I,
I can't be doing that.
I didn't know how to say.
It was like,
I can't be doing that.
I can be doing your pizza place.
I said,
you want me to perform and and for pizza.
I was like,
I can't be doing that.
And then I turned to the guy that was next to us that wasn't with me or him and
I said,
did you hear this guy?
And I was trying not to be a dick,
but I was.
It was amazing.
But it's hard to not be like,
hey bro,
I'm on billboards.
It's hard to do that.
I'm an actual television,
like a real TV show.
It's hard to not be a dick.
Yeah,
no,
I know what you're saying.
It's,
it's a weird situation when someone asks you to do something like that.
But to them it's like stage time,
you know?
That's how they get stage time and they see you like maybe crystal do my room.
The problem with those rooms is most of the people there are not there to see
comedy doing comedy to pizza players sitting this way,
eating the pizza and the stages over there.
Yeah,
and you're,
you're interrupting.
Really.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's kind of rude.
It's not like you set up and play a song.
See if you sat up,
you can just zone out and listen to the music and eat.
Ah,
yeah.
It's no problem.
But if you were like talking about your,
uh,
your eight year old cousin,
that debit details,
I know that requires people to pay attention,
pay attention.
Yeah.
You can't tell a fucking story to somebody who's not listening to the story.
Right.
You'll have like 20 people in the crowd and at any given time,
one person will be paying attention to the story,
but they'll lose you.
And then a new personal pay attention.
What does that talking about?
That people are paying attention.
It's like in short bursts.
Exactly.
So you have the video now?
Yup.
All right.
Jamie's got the video now.
Nice.
I think.
Yeah,
maybe.
Okay,
so here's the dude's,
they'll be these weird wings they have on their cars.
Oh yeah,
I've seen those.
So he spun the guy out.
Okay.
So he,
let's back that up so we could see what happened before.
So that's the guy that he hit first.
Yeah.
That's the okay.
Back it all the way up to the beginning.
Here it goes.
So they're going around the corner.
Yeah.
And he clipped the guy with his teddy.
Okay.
Yeah.
It looked like his,
his tire bumped into the guy.
The guy spun around.
They're all flying.
Right?
It's got,
gets out.
Yeah.
So this guy's pissed.
He climbs out of his car
and he's pointing to them.
You,
you fucker,
you hit me.
You fucking hit me.
Wow.
This is crazy.
This guy's crazy.
He just hit him.
Oh wait,
right there.
Right there.
Boom.
He hit them Christ.
Whoa.
Oh Man.
See,
I don't know enough about what he talking about 25 miles an hour roughly.
And there some people were able to avoid him.
You'd think that they'd be able to avoid him.
I mean,
it looks pretty bad.
Yeah.
Just from,
I don't know anything about it,
but Jesus Christ.
Well,
they're also saying that when you hit the gas,
like,
uh,
your acid kicks out because it's all dirt riding around.
Right,
right.
So when you hit,
he hit the gas on purpose and making these das slide out like he was gonna hit
up the guy like he was going to bump them out of the way and he would certainly
know that as a driver.
Yeah.
Well that's a voc.
You wouldn't know that.
Yeah.
Oh man,
that's crazy.
Well that,
what's the craziest thing about that?
Is it the guy got out,
guys,
crazy fucker forgetting out like that and then running on the track and voiding
cars and pointing at this guy like,
you fucking did this to me.
Like wow.
Also isn't that the game to do that to somebody?
I don't think so.
No.
There's no rule about it.
Apparently.
No rule about accidentally hitting guys.
No on on getting out in the car.
I'm sorry,
I'm getting out of,
oh no,
I just made the track.
What do you mean there's no rule.
They don't have a rule about that.
Like it's,
it's not illegal to get out of your car.
Right.
I'm saying ESPN yesterday I was hearing the debate about should they make a rule
about this?
Fuck.
Yeah,
you should make a rule.
right.
Stay in your fucking car.
What are you crazy?
You know,
because if he got clipped in the car,
he probably would have been fine.
You know,
if like someone came along and guys are,
he did get clipped in the car.
He was fine.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly right.
And at high speed.
Yeah.
Right.
And then there they were at a caution.
So there may be only you have to stay in,
you can get out if your car is on fire,
if like,
if it's a life life,
life changing situation.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Other than that shit.
Yeah.
I can't watch it like that,
man.
I saw an image of that guy stuff,
that terrorist stacking in those three heads on the fucking thing.
And I was like,
no,
I don't know if you saw that.
But that's like,
I remember the first one from the Iraq war where we watched a guy get his head
cut off on video and you can watch that shit.
Well,
I mean,
I can,
I have,
I like it like even two girls,
one cup.
I'm like,
Nah,
Nah.
Oh,
she shits in her mouth.
No.
Good.
Yeah.
Oh,
isn't there a video of you watching that?
Yeah,
that's right.
I saw that video barely.
I posted fear factor for six years and I still had to turn away.
I think about all the shit that I've seen.
Yeah.
But you could throw up in front of me and I never,
I don't gag.
Yeah.
Like my,
that's like,
um,
I'm the in charge of throw up around my house.
Like anytime anybody throws up and I just,
my,
my little girls throw up.
I always cleaned it up.
Well,
my wife just gives it to me.
Like I handle it.
It doesn't bother.
Right,
right.
I'm immune to puke.
It's like,
it used to be when I was a kid,
somebody threw up in the room.
All this extra saliva would be my mouth.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And I would have to look away or I throw up,
if someone threw up in the hallway,
I'd be gagging,
but not now.
It's over.
I cleaned up,
picked the other night and I am a little girl.
My four year old was sick.
It's threw up in the bed.
Who Cleans it up?
Me.
I go in their towels and shit.
Picking up the fucking,
the picking up all the sheets,
putting the puke into a big puke,
like one of those little stork things at the store carries.
Yeah.
My Dad,
the first time I threw up my,
uh,
my,
when I was a kid and my dad tells a story where it's like,
you know,
you don't know what's happening to your body.
You know,
you're like,
what the heck?
I feel weird,
like a nauseous.
And my dad like identified it and he was like,
Oh,
you're going to throw up.
He was like,
this is normal.
Like,
I don't know,
it's 32
stupid jokes.
And,
um,
I don't know.
Young,
young,
you know,
and uh,
he would,
he was like,
you're gonna,
you're gonna throw up and it's going to be fine.
And I was so,
I was like,
oh,
I don't know what's going on.
You don't know what's going on.
And he turned me to him and he said,
look,
it's fine.
Just throw up on me.
You're going to throw up.
And it's going to just go all over me and it's fine.
And he said that that made me relax and he said that I just want to throw up all
over them,
but as this fucking cute I thought,
but it was like,
I just thought that this is funny to think about like the first time that that
shit happens with you as like,
you're like,
that's scary as shit.
Yeah.
It is scary shit.
The first time you're like,
what's happening?
This isn't something trying to get out of my body.
The food poisoning is the worst
food.
Poison the worst when you're just,
when you're just,
when it's coming out in your,
you're screaming it out.
You know what I mean?
Violent,
inadequate poisoning in a wash it,
knock on wood once you've had an a cup
all times.
But uh,
I had it real bad one time in Illinois.
Oh,
it was awful.
I couldn't clench my fist,
like my hands were so weak.
It was just so,
and I just spent the entire night puking and shitting both ways.
Yeah.
What can you do to prevent,
someone told me garlic.
Someone told me if you're,
if you have like some funky shit inside your stomach,
if you eat raw garlic,
raw garlic apparently destroys like a lot of bad bacteria.
Yeah.
You just got to sit down near the toilet and just fucking curl up and
Dale son and just shouldn't puke.
I heard garlic,
I heard garlic is really good for you but it takes a while to get down there.
You're a fucking shit impute and walked away I e.
Bro.
You put it in your ass.
Fucking Cias it down.
Give it an express delivery.
I go like,
I put it on the end of my thumb and I,
I guess
it hits the back of my shit and then just goes right.
Then it goes right down like a shoot.
Yeah,
they didn't to figure that out did it should be a way to scan things.
We out if it's got food
poisoning,
you know like just to me,
why doesn't someone come out with a scanner?
I just something that just can breed the contents of the food was like,
oh this eco lie all of your fucking salad.
Don't eat it.
It'll happen.
You know,
that's the number one thing that people get sick from salad.
Oh yeah,
no,
I,
yeah,
I know that sounds bad.
Be fucking sound.
Yeah.
Salad gives people food poisoned meat but or some shit.
Fish.
Yeah.
You would think it was like bad fish or bad meat salad is because they don't,
not Washington.
It's not washed.
Right.
But um,
yeah.
Well remember all those people were dying from spinach is cause the spinach was
tainted with Nikolai waste from the uh,
from cows and shit.
You found what?
There's a uh,
electronic nose that sniffs out.
Food poisoning.
What,
what to APP and APP sniffs.
Study Cola.
I think you've come on the bottom.
Your phone.
I'll check what,
yeah,
new electronic nose.
Sniffs out.
Food.
Poison.
Isn't it amazing when you,
you say something thinking like this is,
yeah.
Component one of years away from that.
Completely impossible.
No one's going to ever come up with something like that.
How is that possible?
It really works.
It checks the freshness and quality of meat,
poultry and fish.
Wow.
It's an APP.
What's the APP?
Crawler will download that fucker right now.
I might not.
I mean you probably have to have an ignorance to something.
It doesn't look like it.
He or she is.
No Way.
You just take your phone and fucking go like this.
Yeah,
that's what it's called.
Yes.
All right.
I'm downloading that bitch right now and we'll see if it works.
I'm going to put it on Krista,
Leah and see if he's addable.
P.
E.
R.
S.
Okay.
He knows world's first portable,
he knows and it's Ios.
Android mobile APP enables users to determine quality freshness of meat,
poultry and fish and whether it's gone bad and could potentially cause food.
Wait a minute.
It's called p.
E.
R.
S.
What's the name of the APP?
I believe it's what says developers say Perry's or peer.
Perry's.
Perry's right here.
P.
E.
R.
S.
Hmm,
but is this available already prominent assume?
No.
Yeah,
because when I went to p e r e s,
it gives me some Russian shit.
Oh,
back to that spy.
Perestroika.
That's what it gives you.
Yeah.
See that's,
that's what comes up.
Here's the video.
That Russian writing and shit.
See if it says that it's a actually available.
Yeah.
Pull the video up.
Let's listen to it.
The gas is in the sample and adjust play from the beginning so we can actually
look at that fucking bullshit.
Beads go into a green thing.
Detecting food in the USA.
76 million cases of foodborne illness resulting in 325,000 hospitalizations and
5,000 death.
First of all,
pause that.
Estimated to it.
That,
why is that?
I got to talk like that in the USA.
Yeah.
Three hey,
15 million paper.
It just sounds like bullshit already.
Numbers 76 cases of food borne illnesses in
three to five zero,
zero they just 5,000 deaths are estimated to occur each year.
Holy Shit.
That doesn't surprise me.
That surprises you.
That's a lot.
It really,
there's so many people.
That's true of a lot of fucking people,
but 5,000 deaths from food borne illness.
All right,
play it out.
Kurt cheer.
The Paris story began when the team who created the device collaborated with
scientists from count US University of Technology in Lithuania.
After more than a year of research and develop
a team has now created a second working prototype of the Perez device.
Paris works by taking a sample of the air from around the pork,
beef,
poultry or fish by detecting the concentration of volatile organic compounds and
other gasses in the sample and adjusting them according to temperature and
humidity.
It calculates the freshness and quality of the food product using sensor away
and Bluetooth technology data are transmitted directly to a smartphone,
a tablet for calculation of sample data users immediately.
So it's a thing to help them make the transference.
It's smells.
Your food and safety of their pork,
beef,
poultry and fish smell SmartCare
oh yeah,
my fart.
Right into that day or just breaks.
What did your part,
I call your mom,
get Joey d as a fart into that thing and it just sort of wets isn't attractive.
Streamline.
Yeah.
Well if it's another device,
I mean I thought that was your fucking good design,
but saying it's a prototype so it's not ready yet or read it on your iPhone.
But they're saying prototype,
right?
Yeah.
We can dress this guy
we asked you for contribution knocked on upon my family,
but for yours as well,
trust me.
Okay,
give me money and I'm going to make this.
I swear to God it works.
I switched to good in mother's Russia.
I promise you,
and swear to Anna Chapman,
who if I make enough money I can make wedding vow with her,
the Russian spy.
Then she will leave this traitor Edward Snowden and come with me to make food
safe.
Or everyone give money to Kickstarter.
Everybody's got a fucking kickstarted man.
I'm getting a little annoyed when people's kickstarters,
you know there's people that have kickstarters are their like for their own
business and they actually have money already.
Like whatever happened to just investing your fucking money.
You know why?
Why were you trying to steal money from everybody?
But isn't that how investment works though?
No,
I mean they get,
you get other people to invest in it.
Yeah.
But Kickstarter is like,
like it's,
it's,
some of the Kickstarter ones are pretty,
I don't know much about Kickstarter.
All I know is that that people are given Zach Braff shit.
And I don't think that that's cool that they're given Zach Braff.
Zach Braff was the guy who made,
um,
the garden state,
the guy from scrubs.
Oh.
And he
put out a Kickstarter to make fund his next film and people give them money to
make his next film.
And I think that that's cool.
Why are people giving him shit?
Because they're like,
well,
he's made a lot of money.
Why didn't he do it?
It's like,
what are you talking about?
It doesn't how investment works.
Um,
yeah,
I guess so.
That's,
put it that way though,
actually kickstarted.
Makes sense then.
Well,
because people,
because they're like,
well,
I mean,
because movies cost well because movies cost millions of dollars.
That's why,
and yeah,
he's got millions of dollars.
But what kind of fucking asshole is going to be like,
oh,
I'm gonna make this movie.
I'm gonna put $10 million into it.
Mel Gibson,
right.
That's how crazy dash.
Yeah.
That's how he got rich as fuck.
But meanwhile,
I don't think he's rich as fuck anymore.
No,
really?
No.
Apparently.
Wow.
It took a beating.
Mel took a bath.
The ex wife got a big chunk.
The,
uh,
the girlfriend who went chief recorded him.
No,
that was the girlfriend.
It wasn't the wife that was just some Russian chicky knocked up.
But that was with Russians,
man.
Spy in recordings,
spying,
recording very around a Russian.
Very mercenary.
But that was the perfect,
what does this potato salad could ask for $10 to make potato salad on
Kickstarter.
And he ended up getting over $55,000 for it.
So what happens with that?
He gets to keep that money.
He's actually going to throw a party in Columbus and have a big concert and
Deloitte donate,
and I'm like $35,000 to charity and started nonprofit to the closer.
That's a nice guy.
But that's just the updated version of pet rock.
Yeah.
You know the guy who made the pet rock made a fucking kajillion dollars pet rock
made a lot of fucking her.
Now I remember that I was a kid when that was going on the pet rock.
It's ridiculous.
I think that was that the seventies that was before me,
I think.
I believe it was guy.
Basically packaged rocks.
Rocks and that's it.
And sold them and people's doors.
And this is before Internet?
Yes.
Yeah.
And not one person bought them millions.
Yeah,
he made a lot of money.
I'm going to how much the pet rock made?
What do you guess?
I want to bet.
I want to say made 50 million bucks.
Yeah.
Jesus.
How much do you think I can't be 50.
I bet he made about 15 million bucks.
How much do you think Tayga?
I'd say a few million.
Three,
4 million.
Okay.
Marketing corporate director.
Her,
I don't know much about it though.
A few million.
That's it.
How?
I guess I,
I'd like to believe that pet rock millionaire offers new method to get stoned.
That's an actual coupon copy of a newspaper.
Uh,
how much of this Guy Mac development doesn't say,
how could the Wikipedia not say that would,
I would think that would be one of the first things that people at 1.5 million
pet rocks.
Oh,
so then at least how much do they cost?
A few dollars.
Right?
The fad lasted about six months ending after a short increase in sales during
the Christmas season of December,
1975 timing.
Although by February,
1976,
they were discounted due to lower sales.
He sold
1.5 million pet rocks and became a millionaire.
Crazy.
A 32 page official training manual tile titled The Care and Training of your pet
rock was included with instructions on how to properly raise and care for one's
new pet rock.
Notably net lacking instructions for feeding,
bathing,
Cetera,
Perra.
So if it costs five bucks,
homeboy made a lot of money,
made 5 million bucks,
20 bucks.
Now you can still buy the shit that rock.com.
Same Company you think?
Yeah.
Since 1975.
Wow.
Whoa.
Yeah,
yeah.
Since then he sold 10
1975 he sold 1.5 million gone real bad.
Slipped off,
dude.
I don't know what happened.
Six months were great after Watergate.
He would just get really squirrely about their money by blaming.
I'm going to let nine 11 didn't do Mel Gibson one was probably when we're just
playing worst than Kramer or the same.
MMM.
Worse I think.
Not,
no.
Well the Kramer one was worse because it was videotaped.
Right.
That's true.
That you saw in his eyes hate.
That's true it Mel Gibson,
you're like,
yeah,
but he's an actor and you heard it and who knows?
But it was so funny.
It was fucked up.
But she has shut up and blow may,
but it was,
it's fucked up that we're getting a window into this guys kind of feel like you
shouldn't be able to say whatever you want on in your house and,
and it,
they can't use that against you.
Well,
definitely,
you know,
especially because there's a lot of times like we were talking about jokes,
like I have this whole bit in my act about the difference between someone joking
and soon as I saw you do it.
Yeah.
That's good.
But the point is like that when you're onstage in a comedy club,
you should assume that someone's fucking around.
Right,
right.
Because,
um,
I,
you know what you came to see,
you know,
you came to see comedy.
Well,
when you're at home,
you don't expect that other people are going to hear what you're saying.
Right.
So there's a lot of times people just say fucked up shit just to say it and not
even mean it.
You're a fucking con.
I hope you rot at the bottom.
I'm million by the way.
All of dog shit.
And by the way,
you're by yourself when you say that.
Yeah.
Maybe cause why not?
You're fucking home and you're alone,
or you're at home and you've got your Dick in your hand and you're talking to
your girlfriend on the phone and she's been an asshole to you and you,
she didn't,
won't come over and have sex with.
Yeah.
So he just screams because you're drunk.
He screamed some horrible obscenities or you don't mean at all?
No,
and the next day it's on the Internet.
You're like,
I was fucking kidding.
I wasn't being serious.
Yeah.
There's statements,
there's public statements,
and then there's things that can be turned into public statements if they record
you and then just transmit it.
And that's what happened with Mel Gibson that destroyed him.
He was a giant superstar.
Really?
Did he really?
Was that more just the business of things that weren't going well for him or was
he,
he was,
he was at the top of his game.
I can't remember when that happened.
He was at the top of his game.
It was two things happen to him.
Two things have the,
the,
the anti-semite thing that,
to me,
that was what buried him.
But the anti-semite thing was there was no recording.
Right?
Right.
No,
I don't think there was.
Was that come that those cops record everything?
I don't know if there was,
I don't think the,
I don't believe it got out publicly,
but I do believe that the cops were saying that Mel Gibson was calling them Jews
and saying that Jews Control Hollywood and also his dad is like a Holocaust
denier.
And also he was drunk driving,
right?
Yes.
Right.
So the,
that,
that in itself is just like,
oh,
he's a fuck up.
Yeah.
Those things are all bad
drunk driving and screaming about Jews.
Right.
People frown upon those,
that combination.
If you're screaming positive things about Jews and you're hammered,
you're just like,
it's just weird.
You wouldn't lose some validity in your head.
You open your door,
car door,
fuck a beer.
Kids fall out.
He falls.
I love
bagels are the shit who he said a Yamaka on right now.
His Dad is apparently a serious anti-semite,
but enough of those things,
few,
a few of those things will bury you.
Yeah.
You know,
and if you're screaming about fuck,
you can't come over while you're,
why I also think there's a mental illness aspect to it too.
I think some people have something wrong with,
but also how do you be famous for 40 years?
It's super stupid.
Famous how,
but yeah,
no,
not famous.
Like you're on a show,
right?
He's mailed fucking Gibson.
He's,
he's Matt.
Matt.
How do you be famous that famous for 40 years and just be like,
be normal.
We have to ask Tom Cruise with the pull Tom Cruise.
Tom Cruise is the best at it,
I think.
Yeah,
but,
but you see him cracking a little bit sometimes.
It's crazy.
All right.
I know.
But you see him holding it together.
Well,
when he was on the today show and he was talking to that dude,
um,
uh,
Matt,
whatever his name is,
Matt Lauer at Maria about psychedelics or a psychiatric drugs,
right?
Oh yeah.
I remember that being glib about very Glib Chilton.
I,
dude,
there's,
let me tell you something right now.
There's no fucking way.
If I was Tom cruise dude,
I wouldn't even be on the today show.
Might be no,
no,
no.
I wouldn't be allowed there because I would already have fucked up complete.
I would be on buildings screaming shit out positive and negative about you.
It's just everything.
Yeah.
It just,
just,
just who care.
Just I would be the war sky.
There's no way I,
I'm,
I'm on a fucking show kind of and that already I'm already getting nuts.
Do you think that,
yeah.
More power to Tom.
Tom Cruise is amazing for that.
Do you think that the average person could ever understand what it would be like
to be scrutinized on?
Just the level that your scrutinized on?
Just being a sh being on a show,
having people talk shit about you online,
reading Twitter pages.
We,
you know,
communicating with people,
like seeing people talk about you and just,
it seemed that overwhelming hard to not respond to every single one.
Yeah,
it's hard to,
I saw a lady with a fucking crazy hat on the other day at the airport and she's
a black lady and I said,
Hey,
what?
I said something about how this hat looks like you put chips on the top and
guacamole around the side of it and people just wrote racist.
No,
the hats fucking weird looking.
You're a racist because you don't like her.
I was black until people were saying,
I was like,
oh yeah,
cause she's black.
You does nothing.
Fucking racist.
Racist Tom 46 or whatever the fuck.
You don't respond to them.
I sometimes I do.
Yeah,
I have a bit about it that I do sometimes when said it,
just like a guy,
uh,
see I get in with thing with a fuck you fuck you as a,
I say to that person,
I'll fuck your whole family.
And then the person writes back,
I am eight
and he was saying he was a fucking eight year old.
You never know who these people are.
That is a problem.
There's a lot of times you're dealing with like little kids.
You're getting into things with little kids,
but you know you don't know cause you just fuck you.
Oh,
all right bro.
And your board is shit.
You're on the road.
I'm coming for you,
dude.
I used to get in those.
I kind of think,
I can't imagine you didn't,
I can't imagine you didn't.
You're like the Tupac of Comedians.
I'm the Tupac.
I don't know what that means.
Just like fucking like I'll get you.
You know what I mean?
If this happened,
I'll fuck with you.
I'll get you.
I had a guy who was a tweeting me back or it was my space,
my space.
He me back and forth when a way back in the day say really mean shit to me and
then I just engaged him and went back and forth with them and then I put it
online.
I put like our whole conversation online and people got so mad at me.
He just,
he was 20,
I didn't know he was 20.
I know,
but then I started commenting on what I was doing when I was 20 and how he's a
loser in comparison to me.
That'd be funny as shit,
but people,
but people will be like,
Yo,
uh,
people will be like,
like I'll just,
people will make fun.
We'll say you're,
you're a shitty or whatever.
And I'll just,
I'll look at their picture and I'll be like,
you're a six.
Like that's how good looking you are.
A guy or a girl either.
And,
and then and then and then I'll,
we'll get just a,
that's not cool dude.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well yeah,
but you entered the octagon.
I am a,
so I make fun of things.
That's what I do for a living.
Right.
So if you tweet
me,
fuck you and your show you,
you entered the octagon,
right?
That they done.
But then the other people public,
the other people that aren't even involved in it,
then they'll come after you.
Not Cool Bro.
Right.
That's where,
that's where,
yeah,
you get fucked and your and your,
but you know what,
dude?
Whatever,
it's wasted energy and you should stop doing it.
Should not engage.
You should definitely,
that's the right thing to do.
The right thing to do is find the ones that are worthy and make them jokes and
that's take that people have said to you and turn them into bits,
you know,
against the person who said something to you.
Like that way you're not even addressing them personally.
Just taking what they said and then bring it to the stage like,
well,
that's what I did with the thing,
right?
Yeah.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's the way to do it.
It is the way to do it,
but it problem is if you get anytime publicly you get into any sort of an
altercation,
like this is one of the things that I learned about the Carlos men see a
situation when,
when the thing with Carlos went down,
which
if I had to do it again,
I wanted to ask you that.
Yeah.
I would do it again.
In that case would that guy,
that guy's a bad guy.
What he did was bad and what he did,
what people saw was a 10th of what he did.
Oh,
what he did,
he would go on stage in front of guys and do their best bits and then bring them
up.
Really?
Yeah.
On TV shows.
He did it with Johnny Sanchez had a bit,
it's funny.
Fucking bed.
I don't know if he still does it.
Johnny Sanchez.
Funny Guy.
I was always at the store and he was funny.
He had a great bit about this Persian next door neighbor when people were always
parking in his spot and the guy would freak out and he would freak out with
broken English.
Right.
And he's a fucking parking in my fucking parking right?
Yes.
It's very fun.
It's a great bargain.
But he's parking in my parking [inaudible] seen it,
does it on stage on television before he brings Johnny Sanchez up on a
television gig.
He was hosting loco slam one of those shows and,
and Johnny was going to do it.
Johnny was the next act going to do that bit.
Johnny doesn't matter one bit.
It says closing bit,
so when see it does it before he brings him up.
Exactly.
And no one was doing anything about it.
None of the agents,
none of the clubs,
no one was doing anything about it.
And when you would bring it up,
they would say,
this is just business.
Like this was the Gersh said to me,
Oh really?
Gus said to me,
you know,
when they asked me to apologize to him and see you or they were going to drop
me.
Really?
Yeah,
they dropped.
Well,
I told them I would never work with him again.
I said,
I'm like,
I said our,
our conversation's over.
I said,
look,
you guys are already made this decision for,
there's no way I could ever work with you knowing that you will.
You guys do is you sell art.
That's what you sell.
You sell a comedian works.
We,
right.
We sit things,
we sit by ourselves,
we come up with ideas,
we write things down in the car.
We take these ideas,
we tried to craft and we try to turn them into bits like we all do it.
And in what they do is they come along and they sell that art.
They say,
hey,
crystal has got a new hour that he put together and uh,
he's going to go on the road and he's going to give us 10%.
Right?
So they're selling your art.
Right.
And this guy was a vampire.
He was stealing from the artists and they were selling the vampires work.
They were selling what he had done,
right.
But all had done is like take from these other artists and piece it together.
But it was all thievery.
It was all theft.
And they were talking that they were,
when they were saying that he was a bigger star than me at the time and steely
it was,
especially when it came to,
um,
movies and television shows because he had minded Sia.
And it was after I was done doing fear factor and they didn't have me for film.
I was with a another car,
another agency.
Right.
They only had me for stand on it.
And so we had this situation when they were saying that I had to apologize to
him and in their eyes it was just business.
Right.
And so I would have done it again just because it needed to be done.
Like there was a real problem.
There wasn't this like there was like a few minor instances plagiarism or there
was parallel thinking or two guys did jokes about a similar subject and you
think that one guy came up with the other guys bit?
It was,
he was one of the worst plagiarist I've ever seen.
Wow.
And a bully with it.
Like a mean guy.
Like you like the Sanchez thing.
Well that's crazy.
Yeah that,
that's that's,
that's weird.
He would bump guys uh,
when they were headlining like um,
like there would be headlining for the first time like Brad Williams or Brad
Williams or was it,
um,
I forget which guy was but his first gig headlining and Sia shows up,
does a guest spot in front of him for 45 minutes.
Right.
And its first ever headlining gig.
Like the guys finally there and [inaudible] it just goes up and steals his
thunder for 45 minutes.
I think it was actually someone else.
I'm trying to figure out who it was,
but it wasn't the only time he's done that.
Like he would guys,
their name would be on the marquee.
He would show up and bump them.
Like the bumping.
It was a big thing we'd go on right before then.
There was this thing sneak right in.
My point is that the negative stuff that I got from that,
like the,
the people that when two people see or when two people are fighting,
right.
Um,
and then all the public gets to chime in their opinion.
Then you just open yourself up to this like attack.
Even if you're right.
And I was right.
Most people were on my side,
but most people doesn't mean everybody.
If there's a million people that were on my side,
there was 300,000 that were angry at me,
you know,
and the 300,000,
it's slowly eroded to zero.
Right.
It did over time.
Like he still gets hate.
I don't get any from that.
Like over time it was proven that I was correct.
Everybody saw the bill Cosby thing,
right?
All these other comedians came out and then he did mark Marin.
Did you ever hear those podcasts that he did?
I think I did,
yeah.
While ago.
Yeah.
Was that bad?
I don't remember it though.
Bone curl.
Really?
Yeah,
I got it.
What?
Curdling yeah,
I don't remember it at all.
It was ugly because you got to see like how crazy he is.
Especially the first one.
Marion was kind of like,
Oh yeah,
you did it twice.
But the second one was he came back on to address things that all these other
comedians had said about him.
Oh,
all these other comedians who talked about him stealing and then he sort of fell
apart.
Oh,
he's fell apart in the second one.
And then he did that.
I am comic documentary and admitted on Iam comic that he steals people's stuff
and reworks it.
Sort of like a rapper samples bit.
Really?
Yeah.
And he goes,
yeah,
you ever see that?
Pull that up.
Just pull up men's SIA admits to stealing and I am comic.
It's,
it's really,
but what he did was it was after years and years of pressure,
like he's been open about the fact that he had to go to therapy because of all
this and he's just a beaten man.
I mean you look at his,
he's got like 40,000 Twitter followers and he's had 40,000 Twitter,
a lot of Twitter followers for years.
I mean that is who that guy is now like here it is like he's getting
interviewed,
fill out there are going to ask why did they interview Carlos about this?
Yeah.
Carlos is a joke thief.
Carlos steals jokes and we know this and not listen to me and look at me when I
tell you this with all honesty,
if you think that I still jokes,
fuck yeah,
you're right.
Of course I fucking steal jokes.
I out of your fucking mind when I come to a comedy club,
you better run bitch.
You better get the fuck off stage because if anything you say is even remotely
funny,
I'm going to make it mine and all I'm going to do it.
Say Mexican in the front.
I'm like a rapper.
I just sampled shit and make it my own.
What's that really my song?
I don't know,
but it sounds like mine,
but it kinda sounds like somebody else's.
It's a bitch sample sample.
Wow.
I'm that crazy.
But what was it?
What was he joking?
They're like,
what?
What is that like?
He was serious.
I don't know.
Yeah,
he's serious.
That's exactly what he does.
I mean,
he didn't,
he says he's joking though.
That's exactly what this thing does.
That's what he does.
That's a weird,
that's a weird,
I think you do that just,
he's just cracking.
He's just cracking.
Right.
Years and years and years and years and years and years and years of people
fucking yelling at him and everywhere he goes,
you fucking thief.
And then they found out that it wasn't really Mexican,
so the Mexicans got mad at them.
Oh,
you're,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's weird,
man.
Yeah,
it's not good.
But the,
the,
the initial point was that,
that in that situation,
something had to be done right.
But for the most part,
engaging with someone is not worth it.
Right.
Especially publicly,
unless you got like something really important to prove when you do it publicly,
man,
you just open yourself up to so much,
so many idiots opinions,
so much negativity.
It's just not worth it.
It's Harvard and do an interview is though,
and then somebody
asks you a certain question and you're like,
oh,
here we go.
And they get in trouble.
Yeah.
And then they take it out of context and you're like,
that's not what I fucking even said.
You know what I mean?
And it's like,
well,
there's gotta be better ways,
better ways to,
I mean there's,
there's ways to get a point across and then there's ways and not thinking,
but also in the,
in this time we live in now,
it's all soundbite shit.
And when you're asking somebody a question about like,
I did an interview for huffpost and it was like they asked me about something
and then it took a bite of that and they put it onto the headline and it's like
now fucking everyone.
You know what I mean?
It was a wooded four g's a year.
We'll say they're,
you know,
yeah.
It's like that's not fair.
No,
that's weird when they do that.
And that goes back to,
you know me saying it's like,
look,
I think I'm a good guy and you fucking,
they took that and spun it.
You know what I mean?
And Yeah,
when people take things out of context,
context is everything.
It's everything.
It really is.
And the ability to take things in quotes,
like I've had people take quotes that I said like on a Twitter,
like just a Twitter joke and write a whole blog about it.
Right.
And you know,
come up with all these weird assumptions of how I feel about things.
Right.
This whole blog about it.
Like why did they do that?
Because because it's a cheap shot,
cause it's an easy thing to do because it's an easy way to get their attention.
You can talk shit about crystal Leah,
right?
They know crystal is a known character.
Oh Crystal.
He is an asshole who Chris to Leo row.
Oh,
what a piece of shit.
And they'll,
you know,
they'll do things about,
that's one of the reasons why Twitter is kind of funky in a way.
It's like,
well everyone's famous.
Yeah.
Well it's also,
it's 140 characters.
It's just not enough nuance to opinion on it.
Yeah,
no,
that's totally true.
It's just you're not going to really get to the heart of what someone thinks
about something.
You're just going to get some weird snippet that you have to kind of piece
together.
And like,
especially when it's a joke,
right?
Like I'll say fucked up things on Twitter that I don't really mean just as a
joke.
And then people will decide that this is actually your opinion.
You know?
That's true.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
they can't hear it.
I don't,
I don't like,
you know,
I don't,
I'm not into sports,
you know,
and I'll,
I,
when the World Cup was on,
I was just tweeting about how,
how stupid sportswear,
but I was making jokes,
you know,
and it was like,
if look,
if you're a kid and you're coming up in sports is your way out,
that's fucking awesome.
I'm not,
I don't think that kid's an Asshole,
you know?
But people were sending me death threats,
cold cuts.
The World Cup is a Weirdo man.
I know people get super attached to it.
They were like talking sports,
don't me.
I did this thing where I would make like quick videos of like where I was,
I'd be at a bar and there's World Cup will be going on and then some people
would cheer and I will be like,
yeah,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
I would just be screaming.
And people were like,
you fucking piece of shit.
Your stand up.
Doesn't matter if sports don't matter.
And I'm like,
well yeah,
no shit dude.
I'm fucking around.
Guess what?
Standup doesn't,
I know,
you know,
you like stand up and soccer doesn't matter if you don't like soccer.
Yeah,
yeah.
I was a,
I was working on a bit about the annoying white guy that pretends he likes
soccer more than he really does.
Yeah.
Which is like really in Hollywood.
There's fucking,
we were eating dinner at this place and the World Cup was on in the background
and there was these annoying white guys that were screaming whenever the USA one
or the USA scored a goal.
They were like jumping around,
getting their high fiving each other.
It was just like,
it was,
it was like,
there's it,
there's nothing wrong with rooting for a team,
but there's something artificial about the way they were doing it.
It was just too obvious.
Right.
Well,
because it's also,
it's every four years,
they forget about it.
Two years after that and then it comes back again and they're like,
oh yeah,
fuck it.
Whoa.
You know?
Yeah.
Also,
you're not,
you probably weren't even watching the fucking USA game.
They were like,
yeah,
I'm fucking Botswana.
It's like,
you don't fucking care.
I'm rooting for Germany.
Germany has always been my team.
I have a VW,
I love Germany.
It's like I can't,
I don't like anybody who gets to in the sauce and just like,
they're just like,
oh fuck yeah man.
And let's like,
that's not your life dude.
But I have a particular fascination about the World Cup because I find it very
interesting that soccer gets,
it doesn't move the needle at all outside of the World Cup.
Like nobody gives a shit about soccer in America.
And when they tried to sell David Beckham,
they brought David Beckham to La and they paid some fucking ungodly amount of
money to have.
Hence why no one gave a fuck.
Nobody gave a fuck.
I forgot about that.
No one gave a fuck.
They spent so much money to bring David back up to La to play soccer.
And only the only people that watch soccer in la or Mexicans,
right.
They love soccer.
You know,
Mexico has a long history of,
of,
of soccer as does England,
but not in America.
They brought this English guy over to America to play soccer and everybody's
like a,
yeah,
where's Palae Brazilians love soccer.
You know that there's a lot of countries that love soccer.
United States is not one of them.
Wow.
They want to soccer to be big and nobody gives a fuck.
So they try this really high tattooed up English guy bring him over here.
Chicks went to soccer games.
I know girls that went to see a fucking soccer game cause they were in love with
David Becker.
Right.
But that didn't last because they don't care about soccer.
Plus there was a bunch of drunk Mexican
fucking disaster.
They don't,
nobody gives a shit about soccer in America.
I don't know why it meets.
It's more exciting than baseball.
I think soccer is more athletic.
It's more exciting than just because it's about downtime and baseball.
It's mostly downtime.
Yeah,
it's more exciting.
Um,
and that,
which is why I like baseball because it's downtown because of the children.
Cause he's like,
you know,
I was like,
oh he'll,
he'll get it.
I used to love playing,
but I used to go to see baseball games when I lived in Boston.
I used to go to Fenway park.
You don't really have to pay attention at a baseball game.
That's why it's so great,
right?
You can go get a hot dog and come back and be like,
Oh hey,
that guy's still up.
Yeah,
and if you happen to be there when a great moment happens,
some makes a great catch.
Great.
Not a great home run.
Right?
Yeah.
But still it's,
if you try and inventing baseball today,
people be like,
wait,
what?
Right.
That's true.
They'd be like,
this game is retarded.
Like what's going on you?
So you have nine innings and what happens if it's a tie?
You just keep going.
You keep playing.
No.
You know what?
That's actually,
to me that's better than what soccer does,
which is,
hey,
let's play a different game now you just fucking under,
you undersold your whole game by saying it's tide.
Let's do a different game.
You play Jenga,
then play Jenga,
play fucking Jenga.
You're just,
you're just going to kick at the goal.
Now,
which is the exciting part,
which is what should have just started.
That's how it should have started.
Right?
The whole sport should be just kicking in hockey.
We go to shootout,
well,
fuck hockey.
I can't watch that.
I can't watch it.
Here's what should happen.
Baseball,
nine innings at the end of nine innings.
If it's tied the game still over,
they go to hits.
Okay.
Whoever has more hits,
winds,
same hits.
Then you go to fucking errors.
If the other team has more errors,
they lose.
Dude,
you should restructure baseball.
That's what it,
you know what?
In my mind,
that's what it is.
That's a good idea.
Yeah.
That is actually a good idea.
Yes.
Why do you keep playing?
You said,
how long has this whole less nine innings.
Oh wait,
it's the die.
Oh,
well let's go 10 here's the flaw with that problem though,
because what if like one team scored a run because they got four hits.
Like they've got a guy on first and another guy got a single,
you've got on second and another guy got on third and then another guy came
along and had a single and then he brought in the third baseman comes in.
But if you watch like a home run,
like that would like discourage home runs because that's the only one hit.
But it counts as one.
But if you get more runs,
you win.
Right?
But if there's more hits than you don't win,
you only get it if your tie.
And then they hit her more with Lex.
But I wonder,
we probably sound so dumb right now.
Yeah,
we're done.
It's fine.
We're done.
We're ready.
We're dumb already.
Well,
I'm definitely dumb abdominal a lot of things.
You know how I know I'm dumb.
You know how I know I'm done because when I'm doing this podcast,
a time will go by and I'm just listening to you and I'm like,
that's fucking interesting.
And I realize I haven't said Shit.
I legitimately,
I'm just listening to your podcast.
That's a part of podcasting though.
That's means you're good at it.
I know I'm dumb because I get offended when people tell me I'm smart.
What do you mean?
Cause people telling me I'm smart and I go,
oh,
this is wrong.
This is incorrect.
I know what actual smart people like.
Oh,
I know.
I know actual smart people.
I've talked to them.
I know the difference.
I just,
I just have memorized a bunch shit.
I know some things.
That's where that you,
that's when when I,
when I listen to you or talk to you or whatever it is,
whenever I hear you,
I always
think,
how do you,
I,
I just,
before you even know knew me,
I would be like,
how do,
how does Joe Rogan remember that much shit?
I don't fucking remember anything.
I don't know how I remember someone that's,
that's like,
I don't even bother.
I'm at the point now where I'm slightly
by on it,
but I don't,
I'm at the point where I don't even look shit up because I'm not going to
remember it.
And that's satisfying.
If things are important to me,
I remember them.
Yeah.
But a lot of stuff's important.
But the important stuff's important to you to me,
but not unimportant shit.
Like,
like someone will tell me something and I don't give a fuck and then I'll go,
what are you talking about?
And they go,
I just told you I'll go.
Really?
I don't remember.
Yeah.
You know?
So I have a very selective memory.
It's awesome.
If it's something that's actually interesting to me.
Yeah.
You retained shit and you're interested,
which is good.
You have to learn to be interested.
A lot of the time though,
like people,
did you have to learn to be interested or is it usually that people have too
many other things going on that are not interesting so they don't have the time
to get interested?
I think you have to learn to be interested because like you said,
context is everything,
right?
So if you give me a book that's very interesting.
I don't know how to read it if I don't fucking read books.
Right.
And I don't know the context of it.
Like I don't take Shakespeare.
Is that important to somebody who doesn't read Shakespeare?
You're like,
I don't know.
This is stupid.
Yeah.
If you wanted to just go back and kind of look at Shakespeare is like the
origins of literature and the origins of storytelling,
then it,
then it becomes interesting and important and essential.
Yeah.
But it's not an interesting,
like it's hard to take things like do you listen to old stand up?
Yeah.
Do you ever try to go back and listen and Lenny Bruce?
Uh,
I haven't in a long time.
I'm a big fan of standup and Lenny Bruce,
I have posters on my wall at home.
This Lenny Bruce posters from concert films and stuff.
And I'm a huge Lenny Bruce.
I have like maybe four or five Lenny Bruce Pictures of my house.
Cause I think that Lenny Bruce is,
I think he was the godfather of all.
He was the reason why we could do what we did.
Right,
right.
Oh absolutely.
Like for folks who don't realize,
like at one point in time stand up was just jokes.
It was like set up punchline set up punchline and there was these guys that
would tour,
they would do like the Catskills what all do each other's act.
Exactly.
They would all do the same jokes.
Right.
And um,
they were,
they were just joke,
like almost like street jokes.
Right.
And they would put,
they would put together an act and then act would never change.
And then Lenny Bruce came along and Lenny Bruce started talking about things
that he saw a thing,
the behavior people had hypocrisy,
religion,
racism and the left.
But he's like,
what the fuck is this guy doing?
And people would come to see him and they would be blown away.
Like no one in the 50s and the 60s was talking like that.
No one was communicating the way Lenny Bruce was and he lit the fire that
created George Carlin and Richard Pryor and all these different guys.
I think he was the original,
the,
the original source of American standup comedy.
Oh,
that's the Dustin Hoffman,
the movie,
right?
Yeah.
Did you ever see it?
Uh,
no.
It's fucking great man.
I know.
My Dad loves it.
Look,
put it off for a second.
Niggers.
Oh,
I know.
There's one slot and Bob's getting dropped in the show.
Let's see,
there's two niggers and between those two nuggets,
and there's another case that's two catching three niggers and there's a Spec,
right?
Hmm.
He's doing this in an audience that people get a super uncomfortable.
Oh,
okay.
Polak and Oh,
a couple of weeks balls.
And there's three lace curtain Irish mix.
And here's one.
Yep.
Dick Hunky,
Hunky,
boogie.
Boogie.
Jesus.
Right.
I got three.
I got five black guy got sick.
Do I have seven?
I've got seven Niggas told American.
What?
Seven Nigga six [inaudible] five [inaudible].
Three guineas.
One while you almost punched me out.
Did it?
Well,
I was just trying to make a point.
And that is that it's the suppression of the word that gives it the power.
Violence,
the fishes big.
If President Kennedy would just go on television and say,
I'd like to introduce you to all the niggers in my cabinet,
and it'd be just say nigger,
nigger,
nigger.
Every Nigga he saw Boogie,
Boogie,
boogie.
Well,
nigger,
nigger too.
This isn't a whore and Balmy podcasts.
Let's cover why,
because somebody called them a nigger at school.
Is it fascinating what a part of what Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Well he did a great job.
He's like one of the,
that's one of the best.
Like,
well,
you don't seem like a scam.
He was doing,
he did it.
I actually laughed because yeah,
when guys play Comedians,
you just like,
oh,
he's such a,
I don't know.
I don't know how to parent to other people.
Tom Hanks and punchlines.
Yeah.
It's like you can just tell.
You can just tell it's not a comedian.
How about Sally field and line.
Fucking clearly remember that.
I would have to watch that again.
You don't,
you don't have to do that for you,
but that was actually a really good representation of that.
Yeah.
Well,
it's a really good representation of Lenny Bruce.
That's why I mean he,
he played Lenny Bruce and that bit,
boy,
it's,
it's all about the context of the times because that bit like if you did that
today,
like boy,
you'd have to do a way better job.
Right.
Sing it together.
It's just the times are different.
Like back that was at the time what he was doing was like completely
groundbreaking.
Yeah.
I want to never done anything.
You couldn't do that right now.
No,
but it would be a different thing.
But yeah,
if you went and watched him do stand up today,
like if Lenny Bruce was on stage doing standup that you wouldn't be laughing.
Right.
It's too late.
Well,
comedy.
Yeah.
Comedy changes and it's like when you look at the shit back then,
it's not funny anymore.
No,
no.
Even stuff from 20 years ago.
It's not funny anymore.
Yeah.
Isn't that weird?
It's very weird.
You remember those like the number,
the boxer guy that would like punch his face in the eighties yeah.
Bob Nelson.
That was funny.
Yeah,
that's,
did you look at that now and you're like,
what?
And it's just,
that's,
that's fucking crazy dude.
Bob Nelson is the reason why I have my manager.
Really.
My manager was Managing Bob Nelson and Bob Nelson found Jesus and Bob Nelson
decided to get a prayer partner,
was going to be his new manager and so my manager was like,
Oh fuck.
So he had to go find some new talent and so he came to Boston and the ninth that
he came to Boston,
I had written a joke.
I'd only been doing it.
There he is right there.
Shit is so weird place of it.
Hello.
My
name.
My name is Jeff.
I own,
I own a gym.
Okay.
Stop it.
I mean that's,
that's,
this is 1980 opposite of funny,
but it is now.
It is back then he used to kill.
He was a killer.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It was a different time,
but he was always like a real slap sticky.
I don't know.
Fine.
I don't know if he had a substance abuse problem or what.
I don't know like how he got involved with his prayer partner,
how he found Jesus.
I Dunno,
like what was so extreme about it,
but he fired my manager and then my manager,
um,
like just randomly came to Boston.
He was in New York,
just randomly came to Boston and look for talent and I just happened to be up on
stage that night.
It wasn't even scheduled.
Really.
Yeah.
And I've been with them ever since.
Thank God for that guy.
Yeah,
that's it.
But that's how that should happen back.
I never did that set.
You wouldn't have this podcast.
I might not.
I'm seeing you.
Look,
my managers are very important part of my career.
He's,
he's awesome.
He's the best he said and he's a great friend and I love the guy and we'd been
together since I was an amateur.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
I've had the same manager for 22 years.
Wow.
Yeah.
At least maybe 23,
it might be 23 years now.
Yeah.
Crazy.
That's a great fucking thing,
man.
Because,
uh,
that whole thing of like having the right representation that like the whole
situation that I went through with [inaudible],
whether it was trying to get me to apologize to him and see it,
you don't have to worry about that.
If you've got a guy in your corner for exactly fucking 12 years already the
imagine if that was my guy.
Imagine if the garage was my guy and they were telling me that I,
that was the only people I had represented me.
You're telling me I had to apologize to a criminal.
That's the sneaky part about this business,
right?
It's like dealing with all the
people that sell it.
I know.
Yeah.
That's the business part of it,
right?
It's like owners.
Yeah,
but it's like,
who else is gonna Rep who's,
we're not going to do it.
We're not going to fucking just tell me where to go and I'll go.
Yeah.
Can you imagine if the Crista Leah Talent Agency got started?
We'd fucking rap back.
Then we'd rent as his goof.
We'd be like me and him in that fucking thing.
He would open for me.
That's a thing that happens too,
right guys bring terrible acts to open for forum.
Yeah.
We were talking about,
we were talking about that.
I don't get that.
I don't,
I don't get it.
Like I bring,
I bring money guys,
Brent Morin who was the other guy on my show and Jason Callings and those guys
are so good.
Yeah.
And,
and I don't,
I,
you know,
I don't,
I don't get the idea of yeah,
I get a guy,
he's okay and then I'll go up and crush.
Yeah.
Well we were talking about it cause we were at the Improv and the,
you know,
Chris,
very funny act and some guys don't want to go after Chris and uh,
some guys specifically get upset if they wind up having to go after you.
And we were talking about this one guy who kind of tweaks about it and how
ridiculous it is,
is if you being funny takes away from him being funny.
Yeah.
To me.
It's about going up and people being different and it's fun.
And you go up and crush and then I have to go on after you,
I don't want to fucking follow you,
but I do,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
oh,
then it'll be fucking,
yeah.
Oh good.
I get to go after Joe.
It's going to be hard,
but it'll be fun.
I'm different.
But you've done it.
You do it.
You're fine.
Yeah.
The other week,
but I don't,
I never would be like,
no,
no way,
dude.
No Way.
That's,
that's bitch made shit to me.
Bitch made.
Yeah.
To me that w w what are you saying?
You're saying you can't go up and who can't?
Who Even,
how about this?
You bomb.
Who gives a fuck?
But bombing is just,
the whole thing that you've been working for is to build confidence so that you
can get to this point where you finally feel like you're worthy of staying
alive.
And then one bad side after crystally.
But that's the test the universe gives you.
Look,
I we were talking about,
um,
Scott Shore.
Who's Mitzi shores,
I guess oldest son.
He's a buddy of mine and uh,
I ran into him in La Jolla.
This phone when you were there in um,
San Diego this weekend and we were talking about what Mitzi used to do to
comics,
like how she develops comedians and what she used to do is anybody who's any
good she would put you on after the biggest killers she could find like all
throughout my days at the comedy store,
I had to follow Martin Lawrence back when,
when you so crazy when,
when he was doing that
I was an unknown white guy.
The audience was mostly black and he was going on stage with a leather jumpsuit
on.
Yeah.
He was just drawing like people have forgotten how God damn funny.
Mark Morrow,
funny,
I will never forget because he went crazy and he wore like that rubber suit had
gone and just fucking loose running around traffic.
He's still funny when you see him in movies.
He's very fun.
Like he's very funny.
I haven't seen him do stand up lately,
but I don't know if he does anymore.
I'm not sure about the comedy store.
Maybe two years ago and started doing some stuff,
but I never really watched.
Well,
I know he took a long time off and then it came on stage and he was talking
about how they got them on pills.
Oh yeah.
Pretty relatable.
You got to be on pills and um,
yeah,
it was tough action.
And the audience is like,
Ooh,
is this a Ted talk?
Um,
but when I saw him,
that's the thing too.
We're talking about people going crazy when they get so famous.
Martin Lawrence was goddamn gigantic.
He had that show.
Martin norm.
He was doing movies,
big Mama's house and all these little different,
see big Mama's house.
Jim Wright.
Yeah.
Where's it at?
He morphine was that,
America was another big,
big black woman Mama's house.
They all play big black women at one point in time in their life.
But uh,
he did all those movies and he was just a giant superstar.
But what people forget is his stand up.
He was a murderer.
He destroyed and I went on after him.
I don't know how many times,
I don't know how many,
anytime he was performing at the store,
I was going on after him right away every time.
And I was nobody.
I was nobody and I wasn't that good.
I was okay.
So you would get them all on at times and sometimes not.
I would eat shit,
eat shit and then eventually get to like a respectable few laughs before I
bailed.
But the beginning was all just watching giant groups of black people get up and
leave.
They were leaving anyway is when Martin,
yeah,
of course.
You know.
And then he had to bring me up to,
he was very gracious.
He gave,
gave you a great introduction.
And how long would he do?
Oh,
at least half hour.
At least.
Maybe more.
40 minutes.
Crazy man.
I mean when I went on,
when I was in the comedy store,
I would have to,
they would make like,
they would make me go after like Kappa Rolo who crushed.
But um,
yeah,
that's nothing like Martin Lawrence and the fucking,
copper rule is a good comic.
But Lawrence was a superstar.
He was so famous in the 90s.
He was,
yeah,
I would,
you know what,
when I was going to the comedy store,
there weren't people on TV that were at the comedy store.
Oh yeah.
That was the dark ages.
2008.
Yeah,
it was.
It was.
There was no,
literally nobody.
It was,
and these guys are funny.
I'm not saying they're not funny,
but they just weren't on TV.
Keppra,
low Bret Ernst,
Sebastian,
Sebastian was,
this was before he,
you know what I mean?
Like right.
And then,
and dove.
Yeah.
Um,
you weren't there.
This was after you.
It was after I left.
I left in 2007.
That's when the men thing happened.
Right.
And then I went in 2008 and then,
and then I would be going on after these guys that would,
that would crush it.
So I know what you're talking about.
A little bit.
Not like the Martin Lawrence thing,
but I followed Richard Pryor five weeks in a row.
You're dead.
And you know,
that's five weeks in a row.
Richard Pryor did stand up.
I'll never forget,
it was the weirdest thing because he was already on his way out.
Right.
He's
dying.
Right.
And they would carry him to the stage.
Wow.
And,
um,
the audience would clap like,
like fucking Moses at origin from risen from the grave.
And it was just fascinating just to be in the room with them,
man.
Just to be in the room.
Lord love the greatest comic of all time in my opinion.
And he would go on stage and you know him well,
I think I should qualify that.
I think Sam Kinison in 1986 was the greatest comic of all time,
but it was only the greatest comic for a year.
I think he was,
he was a murderer.
Louder Than Hell when he did that.
He couldn't be stopped.
He was just unstoppable.
He was the greatest ever.
But it was a shock when he did the thing about homosexual necrophilia acts.
Did you ever see that?
Yes,
I did.
What's the bit again?
And he goes,
uh,
folks,
it goes,
uh,
there's these guys,
homosexual necrophilia acts.
They were paying,
paying morgues to spend a few hours undisturbed but their freshest male corpse.
And he goes,
could you imagine the lion out there on that slab saying,
well,
I'm dead now.
I guess I'm going to go with Jesus.
And,
and he's like rocking back and forth.
He's lying on his stomach on stage.
He's like,
Hey,
the fuck is this.
It feels like there's a dick in my ass.
You may live,
keeps walking.
It never ends.
Oh
yeah.
To see it.
Yeah.
At the time did,
but nobody liked him.
Nobody even really,
he was so original.
Like there was no one like Kennison before he came along.
Everybody else was doing jokes.
He was Sko reaming
I live in.
He goes,
Oh,
I was married twice.
Wow.
Yeah.
He did a joke about going to hell and about how Satan wouldn't even bother
trying to scare you.
And he goes,
Oh,
you've been married?
Oh No,
this is all old hat for you.
Come on in.
Oh,
that's funny.
Shit.
You had to see him at the time.
Well that's a,
you know,
Kennison is an interesting thing because when I think about Kinison,
I would have loved to seen what the fuck would have happened to him as a comic.
He would have gotten worse.
Well it was all,
but it would have been ugly to I,
I mean,
I'm just guessing,
but he's,
his act was so bad at the end.
Oh really?
He had,
he's the best example that I give to young comics when they,
uh,
want to talk about the perils of fame and what can happen to you.
And when you stop writing,
when you stop working on your sets,
I mean,
you're,
you're not,
you're no longer trying to hone it as a,
as an art form.
He's just,
he was just being Kinison.
He was doing blow and write and being a superstar.
If you listen to louder than hell,
you go watch his first HBO special and watch that stuff,
the good stuff.
Um,
and then watched the subsequent specials.
They were,
they were slowly but surely terrible,
like not as good.
The first one after it was not nearly as good.
And then it got really bad.
And then the at the end,
it was awful.
He just had fallen apart and I got to see him live after he had fallen apart.
Hmm.
I saw him at Great Woods in Mansfield,
Massachusetts and Carla Bo open forum.
Carl,
who's the funny guy,
he wasn't as funny as Carl.
He just,
he'd already like used up all his best material,
all the,
the hunger right from being an up and coming comic,
like years and years of struggle.
He developed like all these killer bits and then within a year he had to rewrite
the whole thing.
He had to come up with all this new material,
right?
Yeah.
And it was just gimmicky stuff.
Like you would have some guy on stage and the guy would tell them about a
heartbreak that he had and then he would bring up a phone and he would call the
girl from the stage and scream at her like that was his gimmick.
Right.
You fucking God,
I'm here with Tom Tar tar.
Right.
Go fucking con.
You're fucking,
I hope you rot are beside under a gas truck and tissue and blood die,
die back.
You can hide
and that's how he would get offstage.
It was,
it wasn't that good.
It was over like it was over like the wind,
the Terry to sales was over.
But during that 1986 year,
Marin has the best fucking stories,
really innocent.
Cause Marin used to work at the comedy store when Kennison was coming up and he
did coke with them.
They really did coke for like 72 hours and stayed up for days and it broke.
It broke Marin's brain,
the port where Marin said that he was hearing voices for almost a year.
Jesus,
anybody who's listening to this,
if you like,
want to hear more of it.
Mark Marin's episode of this podcast.
When Mark Mark Marin was on this podcast,
I'm sure it's easy to find.
He told some fucking awesome stories.
Kennison they were amazing.
Like I would just like my,
my jaw was hanging open,
my eyes were glued open.
Ooh,
fantastic.
But he was there at the darkest moments of the beast.
Like when Kennison was just do wish if I could go back home in time anywhere,
it would be just the 80s and I'd go to the comedy store.
Yeah,
me too.
Fuck Caveman.
I don't care.
I don't even give a shit.
I don't even care Napoleon.
Cool.
I would go see the in 1986 comedy store,
I'm with you 100% yeah.
I would love to see a prior when like the live of the son says trip time,
like during those days.
I mean just people clamoring to get in on a Monday night.
I would love to see that.
Fuck.
I want to see that guy.
The fucking tie down.
Is that Guy Jeff?
What?
Huh?
I want to see that.
Yeah,
no kidding man.
but that's cause you're a real comic,
you know,
you really love it.
You know one of the things,
I saw one of your tweets the other day,
I really loved it or only I would love it,
but only comics would love it.
You like,
all I want to do is be on this day.
I don't want to go to your party.
I don't want to go to the beach.
Yeah.
People don't get it.
Like the,
the rush and the fun that you have when you're crushing,
when you're crushing.
Like I love watching comedy still.
And this is something that I've really come to you do.
Yeah.
I notice you.
That's the cool about you.
Yeah,
I love it.
Yeah.
It's,
I love laugh like when we were watching.
I know it's great.
I love laughing man.
And I love the art form and when Shalon was doing,
I don't want to give his bid away but he was doing this bit and I was howling in
the back of the room cause he was like,
see you added a bunch of new lines to you before.
Yeah.
I love it.
I still love it.
Some people don't man.
And that's something,
if I could give advice to young comics,
don't lose the love as a fan because sometimes comics,
they become comics and then it's all about them.
It's all about getting better and it's all about the them killing and not about
other people.
And then it becomes all about like,
you know,
like you sort of dissect,
like I talked to Norton once,
he was telling me he doesn't watch other comedy because he worries that he's
going to be influenced.
And I was like,
God,
I might have to quit comedy really if that was the case.
Something to be said for that though.
I mean at least he's got a reason and I fricking,
oh,
he's an ethical reason.
But I don't think you can avoid being influenced.
You're going to be,
I'm,
I think I'm influenced by other comics for sure.
I think I'm also influenced by pop culture influenced by art and music and
movies that I see in books that I read.
I think life is,
uh,
the entire culture.
The entire civilization of human beings is a series of influences.
People influencing people,
people enhancing people.
There's a whole,
the whole reason to have good friends,
his good friends enhance you.
Right?
You know,
if you are around people that are constantly like pushing and they're constantly
getting shit done,
like it makes you get shit done.
When I was a kid and I was in high school,
I had my two,
two of my best friends,
Jimmy did Teleo and Jimmy lawless.
Those guys sound great guy friends.
They're the great,
they sound like great guys.
There are two great guys,
but one of the things that was great about those guys is that they worked hard
when I was in high school,
these guys had like,
Jimmy has an electrical company and uh,
he's a electrician and um,
uh,
the other,
Jimmy is a carpenter and a while I was in high school,
these guys like we're constantly working.
They would get up early,
they would do things.
Jimmy had it with Jimmy to tell you how to fucking snow plow operation.
He had a,
a truck that he had bought when we were in high school.
You had a fucking flower and a truck,
a pickup truck had kids,
he'd be me making money.
He was hustling.
He was always getting shit done.
And so I would feel lazy if I didn't like hustle like these guys did.
And I developed a lot of my work ethic from being friends with these guys
because they were hustlers because they were constantly getting shit done.
And if you're around guys that constantly get shit done,
it becomes sort of contagious,
you know,
and I think comics,
um,
they tend to be,
a lot of us tend to be very not
with the best way to look at it is you concentrate too much on yourself to the
point where you,
you will avoid other things being good that don't have anything to do with you.
Like especially like struggling comics.
That's one of the reasons why they don't enjoy watching other standup there.
You're,
you know,
you wish you came up with those jokes.
You wish it was you that was up there.
He see it like I went to uh,
this place cap city once and Jim Norton was onstage and um,
I was watching and beside me with the two guys that were on before,
Jim Norton,
they didn't laugh at all.
Right?
They would just sitting there while he was on stage murdering.
He was,
and I was car ride and laughing.
And I remember looking over and saying,
these guys aren't enjoying this comedy and there was like a tinge of,
I wish it was me up there.
There was a tinge that these guys were exhibiting of I wish it was me.
I wish.
And I was like,
you poor bastards.
Like you're missing out on what?
Why did you become a comic in the first place?
Interesting.
Yeah.
Became a comic in the first place.
Cause you love comedy,
right?
Like I love standup comedy long before I ever thought to go on stage with no
nothing and just say shit and people are entertained.
Yeah.
And the coolest thing to watch too,
like I went to see a bunch of live standup but for ever got paid to do it.
Like I saw Kennison long before I ever did standup,
I saw Kennison and 86 and Mansfield,
Massachusetts at the Great Woods Center for the performing arts and I saw him
again at this place down the Cape and it was all long before I saw Rodney
Dangerfield long before ever saw it.
I thought about doing standup and these guys like that don't appreciate it as
just a thing to enjoy because they do it themselves.
Like guy,
you're missing out on a lot,
man.
It's easy to get caught up in though.
So,
but so it is interesting.
I mean to say that is important I think because it's easy to get caught up in
your own head.
Your own head.
Yeah,
exactly.
Your own head,
your own career,
your own selfishness.
Think about it only,
you know,
in terms of like your success,
like how many comics do you know where other guys will get shit and then they'll
get jealous.
You were talking about that's happened to you like you when you started taking
off like and you started out.
Definitely.
They get angry,
they get angry.
Yet it's,
it's very weird man,
because all the gold,
that'd be no gold fast case,
which is exactly wrong because if let's all go do this.
Yes.
And you can.
That's the thing.
Absolutely.
Especially in comedy,
you get,
you get your crew and I mean,
well not only that,
how about the fact that there's 350 million people in the country and there's
how many fucking clubs?
It's not like there's one club in New York.
We all have to go there and get on stage and there's no god damn stage time.
No.
New York itself has a hundred clubs at least.
Yeah,
just New York.
La Has.
How many fucking clubs are in la?
Jesus Christ.
There's the main ones.
There's the Improv,
the laugh factory,
the comedy store,
and then you've got the ha ha.
Then you've got fucking the Ice House in Pasadena.
You have it all the right in Irvine.
You can go there.
Irvine,
Ontario,
on and on and on.
The comedy and Magic Club in her Mosa.
I mean Jesus fucking Christ.
There's a lot of places to perform here and then across the country,
like everywhere you go,
there's a comedy club everywhere he goes as a place to perform.
If you develop an act and you have a following,
you develop a following,
you're going to work,
you're going to have a great time.
Yeah.
It's,
there's plenty of prosperity.
Just keep doing it.
Keep doing it.
And just,
and also,
yeah,
just fucking don't do one club either.
Don't just be in cap city and just do that.
Yeah.
No,
that's not good either.
Right.
You know,
you know,
one of the things I love about comedy as I still love comedy.
Fucking still love it man.
You know,
I'm getting ready to do the special and I'm filming my special,
uh,
not this upcoming weekend,
but the next upcoming really that sooner.
And so I'm,
I'm hammering it,
man.
I'm doing like,
yeah,
you're always out five nights a week.
I'm having so much fun though.
Cool.
To,
it's cool to see,
to see that.
You know,
you still well,
what's this time?
We did a special two years ago.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And where are you taping this one?
This one's in Denver.
Oh,
right.
Comedy works comedy works in Denver.
Um,
which is one of my favorite clubs ever.
How are you putting it out?
Comedy Central.
Oh,
okay.
Cool.
What'd you do you need to do last one?
I did comedy central.
Yeah.
Where'd you film it?
In New Orleans.
Uh,
yeah.
It was fucking awesome.
It was awesome.
That's a good place to do cause.
Awesome.
Yeah,
it's,
it was such a good place to comedy because they don't,
they don't have any good,
I have a club,
a club scene though.
They have like bars,
but it was awesome.
I was,
I was unsure cause caught me.
It was my first and comedy central's,
we want you to do it here.
And I was like,
all right dude,
I'm so happy.
Did they piggyback you with a bunch of other specials?
They were filming where they had the same stage.
We each had a night.
Yeah.
But yeah,
it was like three nights.
It was me.
Steve ran is easy.
And Neal Brennan?
Yeah.
They like to do that.
They like to do that where they like,
they like get a place.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm doing this one in a comedy club was my first one in a comedy club.
I decided that like,
I'm like,
there's a thing about watching comedy in a liberty.
You're right.
You know what I mean about,
yeah,
absolutely.
It's intimate and you'd just get to do it in a comedy club.
It's just not,
it's,
it's better.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
The shows better too.
It's like there's a difference in the show that you see in a theater.
It's still great,
but it's missing that crackling intimacy that a 300 seat,
250 seat comedy club was,
yeah,
like I just did American comedy company,
San Diego fucking perfect.
I love that club.
Ooh,
it's perfect.
It's the perfect club.
Yeah,
that's perfect.
It can't get any better.
It's just the perfect size and before that I did wiseguys and Utah.
Same thing.
I don't know that one Paul.
I know the name,
but you got to go there.
Fucking rip that place apart.
It's amazing.
And the people are cool as fuck you think of like Salt Lake City.
It's been all bunch of weird religious freaks,
but it's not,
it's only like a percentage of the population and everybody else is like working
really hard to not be like that guy.
Well yeah,
if you have that,
you definitely have the opposite of that in one town.
Yeah.
Where's the places you'd like to work?
I do like the American comedy company.
I love Caroline's.
Caroline Zimbabwe of Caroline's on Broadway.
That's a great place.
I love Addison Improv.
That's all great.
I love that fucking room.
That's a wild room,
man.
It is not a Dallas.
Ooh,
that's a fun place.
My favorite place comedy store though,
man,
it's great spot.
Favorite was that original room?
Yeah.
That's probably one of the best rooms ever.
Yeah,
if not the best.
It's,
it's,
that's like the,
that's like the only room that's built every other clubs built for the audience
that is built for a comedian.
It's like the only room really that I can pick up that's built for you.
I'm working my way to get back there.
I might go back there.
Joey started going back there again.
Joey's my fucking canary in a coal mine.
Joey's one of the main reasons why I decided not to go back to the first bus.
He actually quit before them and see a thing went down.
Oh really?
Yeah.
He didn't like a lot of the things about the way the store was going.
Oh yeah.
It's different now.
I mean we wish it would come back to it.
Don't be hitting awesome.
He didn't get along with Paul either.
Oh gotcha.
Yeah.
I'm there all the time.
Well maybe I will.
Maybe I will.
But listen man,
it's been fun doing gigs with you.
I've,
I've been enjoying doing the Improv.
I've had uh,
yeah,
it's been really fun.
It's,
it's just been fun to have somebody not in the group.
Not In the green room with,
yeah,
cause there's no bedroom there.
We were talking about the Improv in Hollywood is like if we were on the road and
like we,
we worked at that club,
people like there's no fucking green room is nowhere to stand like in between
shows.
You just get like weirded out because all these strangers that glom on dia and
sometimes you know,
and I will use each other.
We'll be like,
yeah,
just here hanging out.
I will fucking be,
hey,
connects to each other and somebody
you're showing each other.
Nothing.
By the way.
We pretend like we wanted to go.
See now I want to see this guys act here.
Well,
let's go in.
Let's go into the showroom now.
Comedy.
Nothing like it.
Yeah,
no,
it's been fun to do it.
It's been,
it's been cool.
Like rolling with you and,
and,
and just be in near you and doing that shit.
It's been real fun.
It's been fun doing a podcast.
We just hit three hours.
It's over.
Yeah,
that I kind of went quick.
Flew by.
Hope.
We hope it flew by for you too.
Ladies and gentlemen,
if it didn't fly by for you,
we apologize.
But that's,
that's on you.
But we don't really say sorry.
Remember,
we don't really give a fuck.
All right.
That's it
as the end.
Uh,
thanks everybody.
Thanks for listening.
We'll be back on Wednesday.
I got mad fucking park tests this week,
ladies and gentlemen,
a stamps.com thanks to stamps.com use the code word j,
r e for your special bonus offer $110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale which you are not allowed to use for mushrooms
were also brought to you by Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com use the code word Joe and save 10% off your first
purchase,
squarespace.com we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o.
N.
I.
T.
Use the Codeword Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
you fucks.
We'll see you soon.
Until then.
Yes.